Hey!
I just realized I forgot to set up some stuff.
I'm already live!
We have to set stuff up?
No, for my end.
I meant my end.
I thought we had to do stuff for the Tribals.
No, no, no.
I mean like I need to have you guys on my screen.
I forgot about that.
There was something I forgot about.
Oh wait.
Why do you do the Discord overlay?
It's like... I use Fugi.
Oh crap.
I'm just too lazy now.
Yeah, no.
If I wasn't a streamer, I'd be lazy too!
I was like, wait a minute.
I knew something was missing on my screen.
Something very important.
Where the fuck is this guy?
Alright, here you go.
Hey, where are you?
You're not on my screen.
Where is this?
Sorry, very professional chat, I know.
This is...
We're starting off very strong here.
Alright, there's you.
You're gonna be far away from me, Tempo.
So, hello everybody.
I hope Tempo is not too loud.
Hello.
I hope he is not too loud, guys.
Am I not too loud?
I don't know, actually.
Your mic is like... you're like in a very empty room.
That's what...
Great.
Your room has... definitely has no soundproofing.
Wait, wait.
My mic has four things.
It has...
Yeah?
The Olympic circle thingy.
What the fuck does that mean?
It has just a circle.
It has something that looks like a fortune cookie.
Oh, wait.
Do you have a blue yeti?
Yeah.
Okay, yeah.
I was gonna say, that sounds like a blue yeti shit right there.
So, what do I do?
Fortune cookie?
I don't know.
A cookie, a circle, or the Olympic thing.
Sound people.
What does... what should he do?
I... okay, you...
Yeah, sound people help me out here.
I'm not like a sound person.
What the fuck do you... why would I know this?
It seems like...
No, you're a streamer.
I thought... I thought you knew.
Yeah, I'm a streamer that outsources to other people on things that I don't know.
Like, sound being one of them.
I'm just here to choose things that look pretty.
That's really all I do.
Like...
You think I know anything about sound?
Oh, you want fortune cookie.
Everyone says fortune cookie.
I am on a fortune cookie.
Why the fuck do you sound like you're in an... do you have any like... like...
I have stuff in my room.
Do you have like any... it feels like your room is like super empty.
That's what it sounds like.
I think because my door is open.
Does that make a difference?
Bro, I don't know.
Does it actually?
Yeah, he sounds like you're... it sounds like you're in the bathroom.
Someone's like pad your wall.
That's true.
I was gonna say that too.
I was gonna say like push shit around your room.
Door is closed.
Does that change anything?
I guess it like improved a little bit.
It's like a little bit better.
But it's still... it's so weird.
It sounds like... yeah, it sounds like you're literally in a bathroom.
That's really it.
But my room has stuff in it.
Yeah, but you need stuff on your walls.
Oh, there's nothing on the walls.
Yeah, that's why.
You need stuff on your walls.
That's why.
Should I just fill it with all those posters that...
Yeah!
Your fans sent?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'll send you a list.
Wait!
Wait, you should!
Just all the acoustic Doki posters?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It'll give you better soundproofing.
You should.
I'll give you a list of artists to buy from.
And then...
Okay, Doki artists.
If you have any...
Doki prints sent up on Etsy or anything, let me know and I'll make Tempo buy them with his own money.
He has a TSM money.
Which isn't a lot, but like...
Sorry, I should say that.
But if you get paid very well, Tempo...
TSM money, which is it?
You get paid very well, Tempo, for what you do.
Oh, no.
Don't worry.
I was spreading misinformation earlier, guys.
Don't...
Don't put this on any eSport reporting news that a VTuber just...
Exposed payroll.
Guys, it was just a joke.
I swear.
I... I am so warmed up.
Now, I can't wait to...
Not hit any of these shots in the actual game.
Is... Is like...
Is like Wig still in the interview?
That's such a long interview.
Where is... Where is Wig?
Oh my god.
I like how like...
Wig is like... The name of the tournament.
But...
Greek is Cassie.
Wait, Greek is Cassie?
Isn't he playing?
Yeah.
Isn't... Wait, isn't he... Is he playing?
Yeah, he's playing.
He's playing.
He's on one of the teams.
Why the fuck did it say Greek?
Oh, it says Geek Lounge.
I thought that said Greek.
That would be so funny though.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
In interviews.
Got it.
That would have been so funny though.
If like Greek was the one casting it.
He should have cast it.
He should have casted it.
He should have... It would have been so funny.
It would have been really funny.
Also, guys.
How is...
How was Tempo?
Should I raise him up or should I keep him this volume?
I don't know if Sound Guy is awake right now.
I'm still in the bathroom, so it's okay.
Yeah.
Tempo sounds good.
I'm playing from the toilet.
Yeah, he is.
So, we do pretty badly.
To be fair, there's a lot of things against us right now.
Wait.
Where... Where are the... Where are the listed teams?
That's not it.
It's in announcements, I think.
Guys, I just want you guys to know.
I'm going to talk about this again when Wick joins us.
But like, our team technically consists of two Plat players.
And a Gold player.
Because... Wait, Tempo.
You're Gold, right?
Who's the Gold player?
I'm in Plat.
You're in Plat?
Oh, three Plat.
Wait, no.
Is Wick in Gold or Plat?
Wick said he was in Plat.
It's three Plat players.
Oh, it's three Plat players.
Okay.
It's okay.
I put two Plats and a Gold for... to increase engagement.
Wick's the Gold, right?
It looks better when I have a Gold in my title.
Because people are like, whoa, and a Gold player?
Okay, let me go derank myself here.
Yeah, I mean, that would be easy.
Where am I?
Actually, I'm very close to deranking.
Okay.
Spoiler reviews.
Anyway, so our team technically consists of three Plat players.
And the thing is that...
If you guys watched the drafting stage on Wick's stream, I was on the list and it listed me as Plat 4.
Because technically...
Technically, I had Plat 4 as Doki Bird.
So, I was listed as Plat 4.
So, no one... so, like, people were like, who the fuck is this Plat 4 shitter?
Yeah.
So, I committed the greatest heist of all time.
Convincing staff I was Plat 4.
I did say... No, I did it right.
I was like, ooh, Masters, but I play like a Plat player.
So, that's why... I literally said, okay, the reason why I was in Plat 4 was because they were like, what's your rank?
And I was like, well, I got Masters in the last... was it five seasons?
But, technically, I play like a Plat player.
And then they're like, okay, give us your, like, tracker thing.
And apparently, the tracker lists your average rank overall.
And my average rank overall on... as Doki is Plat.
I got away with it!
Yeah!
I can't believe it!
I can't... how does she keep getting away with this?
How does she keep doing this?
Oh my god!
It's so fucking crazy!
Somebody stop her!
Change the bat... oh, don't worry, don't worry, guys.
Don't worry.
I'm way ahead of you.
So, I improved!
Don't worry, guys.
I thought of this, too!
I thought of it, as well!
I do... I have one singular Plat badge.
I just need you guys to know that.
All... out of all the badges, I actually have one singular Plat badge.
Okay, here, let me show you guys.
Where's the badges?
Look.
We're gonna ignore that.
Look at that!
My... my one singular Plat badge!
Right here!
We're gonna ignore the other badges, chat.
We're gonna ignore the other ones.
We're gonna look at the ones that matter right now.
Alright?
The ones that matter.
Welcome back.
Hey, welcome back!
Thanks, dude.
So, how was the interview?
It was good.
They said, uh, hope you win.
And I just started laughing.
Oh, because we're totally gonna win, right?
No, for sure, for sure.
Wait, wait, wait.
What about now?
What do you mean, what about now?
What do you mean?
Does it still sound like I'm in a bad mood?
Oh.
Yes.
Fuck.
You, you, yeah, it definitely does.
A little bit.
Wait, I just realized.
Oh my god.
They, like, locked out some of the badges because they haven't fixed it yet.
Oh no, really?
I just realized that.
Because I was like, wait, I am missing badges.
What the fuck?
My Plat badges, of course.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm missing, I'm missing my...
Plat badges.
Yeah, yeah, my Plat badges.
Because, like, for some reason on my count, I only have one Plat badge.
But, like, obviously, I'm a multiple Plat player.
I have a lot of Bronze badges because I was really bad at one point.
And then I improved to Plat.
At one point?
Yeah.
Specifically, there's one point where you were bad?
No, no, I literally have, like, six plus Plat, uh, Bronze badges.
Do you actually?
I thought you had a Flagstaff.
I kind of want that.
I do.
I'm, okay, wait, wait, wait.
How do I go see my badges?
Check out my stream right now.
Check it out.
Don't worry.
I thought of this too.
If people were like, wait, she's not Plat, don't worry.
I am Plat because I put my badges on.
All that matters is you got the badge on account.
Yeah.
We'll be sharing the first usable legend here soon.
Okay, cool.
Alright, nice.
I didn't mean to cut you off.
You're streaming on, you're streaming on Twitch.
I was like...
Yeah, of course, it's Twitch Rivals.
Why would I be streaming on Twitch?
I don't know.
It's literally Twitch Rivals.
Alright, let me put you...
Let me add you on the screen here.
Damn.
You got some nice bronze badges.
Yeah, you like it?
Yeah.
Yeah, you know I improved as a gamer.
Because like, I went from bronze to Plat.
I'm at my peak.
I'm at my peak right now.
Yeah.
Codes out!
Alright, I need to apparently raise up...
It's alright.
I'm not going to be the last person joining in anyway.
It'll be fine.
It's no way.
I can like...
Okay, wait.
Ready?
We have our comp here.
List of legends from map one.
Okay?
Fuse, Mad Maggie, Horizon, Revenant, Bloodhound, Rampart, Watson, or Gibraltar.
Wait, can you repeat that?
That's a lot of people.
Assault.
Okay?
Assault is going to be Fuse, Mad Maggie.
I can read it.
Skirmisher is going to be Horizon, Revenant.
Recon is going to be Bloodhound.
Controller is going to be Rampart, Watson.
And then the last one is Gibraltar.
Okay, we clearly need like a ring reader.
We need somebody to read the ring and we're going to survive here.
That's what people are probably going to do.
They're probably going to go Horizon, Blood, Watson.
Yeah, you know all the pros are going to take the blood.
Okay.
And run everything down.
Yeah, Wig.
Our captain.
Yeah, you're going to run everything down.
Yeah, right?
Right, Wig?
Hell no.
I'm the player.
I'm playing live.
What do you mean, Wig?
You really are Captain Pro.
It says, it says Captain Pred Pro.
Are you trying to say you're not professional?
Did you lie on your resume?
You lied on your resume.
Yes, of course.
My LinkedIn was a complete fucking lie.
I shouldn't even be here in the first place.
Fake it till you make it, I guess.
So are you playing Fuse?
No, we need somebody for control.
If Tempo wants to play Fuse, I'll play Bloodhound.
I'll take the L.
Yeah, that's fine.
Okay, that's great.
And then I guess I'll play Watson then.
So we're playing Watson, Bloodhound, Fuse?
Fuck it, dude.
Lock me in.
I'm so down.
We need somebody to read the ring.
I mean, no, I agree.
Yeah, you're right.
We're starting off on World's Edge, so I play Geyser.
So we're Geyser.
Sorry, that's not the best POI.
You gave us Geyser?
I know, I panicked.
You're literally the fucking headliner.
You can request for any fucking POI.
I know, I panicked so bad.
And then we have Tempo that can kick off any pro player off the scrims.
I know, I know.
If they try to contest us.
I know, I got scared.
I said abuse your power, not be a bitch.
Oh, but I'm always a bitch, man.
I'm always a bitch.
Bro.
Oh, I'm always a bitch, man.
What happened to you, man?
What happened?
I've been this way.
We had to go back to childhood.
I don't know, dude.
What?
I had this emotional trauma.
Whoa, how long ago?
How long ago did I become a little bitch?
Yeah, become a little fucking bitch.
Shit's good.
I mean, Geyser's... realistically, Geyser's not awful.
It isn't.
No, it's pretty.
No, it's pretty awful.
No, you guys are just coping now.
Does the flying thingy... does the flying thingy...
no, it's pretty awful.
No, you guys are just coping now.
Does the flying thingy still go through Geyser?
What?
The... the...
The what thing?
The Evac tower?
The ball thingy.
The Evac?
No, the...
What the fuck is the ball?
What is the ball?
The flying ball.
The drone that flies with the ball.
What?
Why is that...
Why am I forgetting what that...
The drone...
You're talking about the loot tick?
Are you talking the loot balls?
Is that...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm so sorry.
Guys, I'm just... not bottom five.
That's my goal.
What do you mean, not bottom five?
Oh my god.
He watches Apex every day and said the loot ball thingy, dude.
Wait, no.
The loot tick is the...
The cargobot.
Cargobot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The loot tick is the thing with the legs.
Yeah, cargobot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, but he said the ball thingies, you know?
Yeah, it's a ball.
He said it as if it's like something we fucking take, like a fucking...
The tower.
Oh my god.
Okay, the lobby is open.
I'm heading in.
Guys, we're gonna...
We're gonna...
Not bottom five.
I'm actually not gonna use charge rifle and no one will run at us.
Let's go.
Okay.
How good are you with the Sentinel?
Bro.
Can we just run three snipers and just...
...go somewhere high and then just try and snipe people and get kills that way?
And just make everyone angry?
Okay.
I'm gonna...
We just...
The way to get to that area is that we have to make sure we don't dive to travel there first.
That's the...
We have to make sure...
No Valk is gonna be our crutch here.
We're fucked.
That's gonna hurt us.
We have no Valk.
Yeah.
Remember, we need three evac towers.
Well, last time we played...
Well, actually, no, we didn't play.
But last time, you know...
Last time you and Tempo played.
I played.
Yeah, with me.
I would say that we had Valk because we literally needed it.
Now we don't have it.
But no one else has Valk too.
We're playing without Valk or an evac tower.
Okay.
So at this point, we just gotta hope RNG are...
Wait, wait, wait.
You have connections to Saf, right?
Can they...
Just spawn some evac towers in front of us?
Like rest...
Grig just came to my chat.
Grig just came to my room and said, if Tempo kills me, I'm pulling the fucking ethernet cable.
So Tempo, if you kill him, bro, my internet goes out.
Just know it was worth it.
Yeah, but his internet goes out too.
He fucks over his phone.
No, he's just gonna come in mine and pull mine.
But he's gonna pull mine.
But you can go over to his room and pull his as well.
Yeah.
I can't pull out Hal's internet.
Throw his PC.
Yeah.
You can pull...
Okay.
Tell Hal if he kills us.
I'm in the house alone.
Everyone's...
I can't pull out anyone's internet.
No, you...
Wait.
Oh, wait.
How...
Okay.
Does any TSM member live with you?
They all do, but no one's here.
No, but you can be like...
Just log in on his computer and then it'll just...
I'm just gonna...
Disconnect him.
No, no, no.
Threaten their PCs.
I'm gonna install Destroyer 2009 on your PC if you kill me.
Okay.
To be fair, I was gonna say like throw their PCs out, but you can do that.
See?
That's true.
But keep this mad for their PCs.
Threaten their PCs.
You literally have...
They're like babies right now.
That's like the way to go.
Hold on.
Hold their PCs hostage.
Exactly.
Someone in my chat said, hold their PCs hostage for first place.
Oh my God.
We're cooking.
Someone...
I'm so happy I didn't listen to any of that and just...
I literally come back to we're cooking.
So I just know that was an absolute shit show of words that I shouldn't have heard.
No, we're discussing about how Tempo should hold TSM PCs for hostage.
So it'd be like your PC's gonna get ransomware if you kill us.
Oh.
Holy fuck.
Bro, they're gonna be so scared.
They wouldn't wanna kill us after that.
We're gonna do so well, guys.
Not bottom five.
That's all I would ask for.
Bottom five.
No way it's bottom five.
No way.
There's no way.
And if we do get bottom five, the system hated us.
We were too good to play their games.
No, listen, I'm gonna tell you right now.
You guys, listen, I have the right to...
Are you sipping something or laughing?
No, I'm sipping...
He's just laughing at you.
I was like, this is gonna be a serious game.
The Lulu mode.
Listen, I can get us where we need to be.
Okay.
Okay, how?
We just...
I don't know yet.
We're gonna figure it out.
Okay, okay.
Okay, I thought you figured it out already.
We don't have a Valk.
A Valk was really easy for me to get us where we need to be.
But, I'm telling you, if we get there, I think Tempo's gonna pop off.
I'm serious here too.
I'm not lying.
Okay, how much you wanna bet?
We don't have to bet anymore.
No, no, no, no, no.
I wanna know what your money is.
Like, how much you wanna bet?
I'll bet you a second blended Subway sandwich.
We didn't do the first one.
I can't trust you on that.
You didn't do it either.
I was waiting for you.
Technically.
Technically, I'm free from that already.
Oh, wait.
That's bullshit.
No way.
Technically, I'll keep it.
Doki Bird didn't promise a blended Subway.
I'm just saying.
I'll give you five subs that Tempo gets.
Five?
Well, actually, how many kills though?
You know what I mean?
That's how much you believe in him.
Five subs.
That's how much.
His life is worth five subs.
That's like how many dollars.
That's like...
Don't gaslight me.
You're playing on his downfall.
You're saying he's so bad.
No, I wanna know how much you believe in him.
But clearly, you don't believe in him enough if it's worth five subs.
Alright.
Yeah, you couldn't be more right.
I'm 100%.
Yeah.
No offense, Tempo.
I love you to death.
But like, I'm not gonna sit here and say he's gonna get like ten kills.
I think Tempo gets like five in six games.
I can't believe... I can't believe he's...
Like, if he gets a kill, it's gonna be on a pro player.
So you're trying to say that his pro player kills aren't even worth more than that?
I'm trying to say that he's worth more than one sub per kill.
There we go.
It's not even worth one.
Wait, I'm playing... wait, wait, wait, wait.
Only allowed legend is Fusing Mad Maggie Horizon?
Wait, what?
Revenant Bloodhound.
Oh, there they go.
They're going.
Revenant Bloodhound.
Oh, there they are.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Bro, do you mean...
Watch the developer, yeah.
You're trying to say Tempo is worth like $25 in kills?
Correct.
Bro!
Yes.
Question.
If I had to pay Tempo to be on my team for $25, I'd pay him $25.
Oh!
What are the odds someone ends up with negative points today?
Who's Selene?
What?
Wait, say it again?
Oh, yeah.
Say that again.
Who the fuck is that guy?
Who the fuck is that?
I don't know who the fuck Selene is.
What a fucking bum.
Yeah, I'm Doki.
Yeah, what are you talking about?
It's my first time meeting Doki.
Yeah.
Okay, five subs.
Okay.
If Tempo does... wait, wait, what was the deal again?
If Tempo gets like a $25, he's gonna be like, oh, I'm gonna get a $25.
That's what I'm saying.
One kill, it's five subs.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
You're making...
Holy shit.
Wait, one kill, five subs?
Shit, no.
No.
Doki made...
I didn't say that.
I can get a hundred subs here.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
If Tempo gets one kill, you have to gift me and Tempo five subs each.
Oh my God, imagine, imagine Destroyer actually gets in his lobby.
Holy crap.
Also, if he doesn't, you have to gift me five subs.
All right, down.
I don't know how I always get wrapped in these things with you, but it just matters.
It's fine.
Yeah!
We did it!
Of course you did it!
You do it every time!
You're so good at it!
Because you're such a little bitch!
What?
That's insane to say!
How am I a little bitch, bro?
I'm a bitch for believing in my friends?
Now you don't agree that you're a little bitch?
You literally told me you've been a little bitch since you were young!
No, how no!
I'm not a little bitch.
You literally told me you've been a little bitch since you were in 6th grade!
Or since you were 6.
And now you're not?
No, no.
Actually, today's the day I change.
I'm not a little bitch anymore.
Today's the day you change.
After giving us Geyser as a drop spot.
Hey, hey!
Listen!
I got command center!
That's pretty fucking good!
For the next map.
I got that too!
Maybe I am still a little bitch.
Holy shit!
Hey, listen.
I'm gonna do this.
Drop Geyser.
Ready?
Look at me.
Banned from Torni.
Oh fuck, I spelled Torni wrong.
FYI.
Yeah, let him know.
Because Nox is thinking about where free kills are now.
I guarantee it.
And then he's licking his lips.
Just be like, if you kill us, Wake isn't gonna watch part of your team.
They might be thankful for that.
Oh shit, no.
You will watch their team.
You kill us, Wake's gonna watch your team.
No one should drop on us.
I told them they don't get any DC restarts that they do.
Oh my god, you're a genius bro!
Nice!
You're a genius!
Hold them hostage!
Fuse, tempo fuse.
The only free skin I got.
Who am I going again?
Bloodhound.
And you're going Watson.
Yeah, I'm going Watson.
We didn't get negative five.
So that's good.
If someone goes negative, we have to be mean to them.
We have to be mean to them.
We're doing this show in messages, we have to be mean.
Yeah, yeah.
Just spam, who's negative five right now?
Who are we restarting for?
You gotta be mean to them.
We got this.
I can't beat you up, Max.
Okay, wow.
Where am I landing?
Pass it to the little bitch, I guess dude.
Yeah, the little bitch who's captain.
Yeah, yeah.
Little baby.
I'm trying to build up your confidence.
That's why I'm giving you Jump Master.
You just called me a bitch like 40 times.
Yes, but if you cry about it, then you are.
Now you can build it back up.
Yeah, what doesn't kill you makes you stronger.
You're so right.
Words will never hurt me.
Exactly.
Only in high school.
They really hurt in high school.
Hopefully the zones cost.
We're not getting a contestant, right?
There's no way to contest this.
It's fucking Geyser.
I'm not gonna leave in the game.
It's like, what the fuck do you want Geyser for?
It's literally the shittiest drop ever.
I should've went No Name.
I'm just gonna go through tunnel.
I'll go through tunnel.
We have no beacon.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're off to a good start.
We could go to Overlook and get it.
Wait, there's Gents killing more.
Oh, it's not fucking anonymous mode.
Yeah, it's not anonymous mode.
It's okay.
Don't restart it.
We're fine.
That's one less team.
Don't worry about it.
True, actually.
I'll tell them to put it on for the next game.
Alright.
They didn't have it on during, what's it called, either?
The Asia Festival, right?
Uh...
I don't remember.
I don't think it's common to have it on.
Yeah.
For Asia, isn't it?
I think you're right.
It's been a while since I played Asia tournaments.
We can grab two charge rifles, Vig.
You already have one?
Do not listen to the dark comments in your mind.
No, that's low-key low-key.
It should be the most annoying team in the game.
Do not listen.
I don't have a backpack, bro.
Okay, we're off to a really, really good start.
Bad start.
No, no, no.
It means you're gonna get purple backpack later on in life.
Yeah, yeah.
Next game.
Next game you'll get a...
Okay, here's this.
We'll take this.
Okay, guys.
Thank God we don't have to...
There's no armors left on the floor because...
I don't think we were ever gonna find armors in Geysi.
No, we were probably gonna get just triple white anyway.
Yeah.
There's no difference now.
Geysi was like...
Yeah, Geysi was pretty bad.
It's not like awful.
No, it's fucking awful.
What do you mean?
The little drone is flying by.
It's okay.
Yeah, you can shoot the drone.
Do we have a Valkyrie?
Yeah.
No.
Why would you think we have...
The little drone did not come this way.
Who didn't ping it three times?
Tempo.
It's really cute that you think we'll have anything.
Okay, wait.
Where do we go?
I'm trying to think.
We gotta craft up.
Craft a bat real quick.
I have nothing.
I'm gonna craft... I did.
I'm gonna craft a bat right now.
We have four bats.
I'll craft a bat for you.
Okay.
I'm gonna hit this raven and just see where people are going.
So we're not getting routed.
Wait, they might be routing that tunnel.
I think I saw someone.
One second.
Okay, because I'm crafting this.
If I get shot, I will craft it.
No, we're good.
We're good.
I still need a backpack.
It's crazy.
Here.
Here's a bat.
I'm pretty sure I saw a white backpack.
Maybe.
Alright, we should try to rotate it where a beacon is.
Where is beacon?
Well, big mod's probably still over there.
So I don't know if I want to go that way.
Oh, thank you.
Siphon's pretty shit.
I mean, we could just rotate it.
There might be multiple squads rotating in that way.
There's no siphon sign.
Let's just start walking up.
Alright, I believe in you.
I don't have any e-box hours.
Anyone?
Nope.
We are in an awful spot for our rotations.
There's a pack right there.
I don't know if...
Alright, who's gonna get it?
Look at all of us.
Let's start moving up.
Alright.
We're very not so good right now.
I'm gonna go get it.
I'm gonna cover you.
I'm watching with the charge rifle.
I am shooting fences behind us.
Okay, I'm dead guys.
That's fine.
I'm so fucked.
The one in blue armor, that's okay.
We're so fine.
They're dropping down guys.
They're dropping down.
They're heading to...
I'm in that area.
I forgot what that is.
I got an R301.
Suck it bitch!
Yeah, fuck them up.
Tempo.
Tempo, go Tempo, go.
I'm reloading.
Are they moving through?
They already crossed over that.
Are they in the building?
I don't know.
They ran back into siphon.
I'm gonna come up and scan.
We should try to get one of these buildings and move in.
I'm gonna scan one sec.
We're right behind you.
I'm gonna come up.
Nice job Tempo.
Oh my god, Tempo's doing it.
I have 12 nades.
If we can just trap someone somewhere, I can just...
If we can just trap someone...
Let shit loose.
I mean, I have a gold R301.
Realistically.
No matter how bad I am.
13 nade.
We wanna keep moving in a little bit though, cause I don't see anyone posted up here at all.
We wanna keep moving?
We're gonna keep moving.
I'm just gonna keep scanning so we can get routed on.
I'm right behind you.
Guys!
We're not 20th!
No, that's huge for us.
We're making waves!
It was Keon!
It was fucking Keon there.
Did no one nade Syphon?
No, no, no.
There was.
I think Halcon.
Oh my god.
I don't think this whole side's looted though.
That makes me definitely think it's towards the...
Definitely this is not... this is not Zoom.
I have 12... I have 20 shield cells.
Alright, we need to go middle.
We need to take this guy on to lacrosse.
Alright.
I mean, we have...
Oh, there's a ring council!
Yeah, that's where we're gonna go hit.
There was a team here 30 times ago?
Yeah.
Get in the house!
I mean, car.
What the house?
Alright, if there's a team here, just stay on the gondola.
I'm not kidding.
I can stick him with my arc.
Alright.
Okay, someone protect me while I do the ring council.
Yeah, this is extremely sketched, but I think we should...
Yeah, I mean, if I die, you can craft me.
Wait, we don't have anybody to craft.
Okay, nevermind.
No, we do not craft you.
We don't have it.
I'm just dead.
Okay.
I'm pretty sure we're like the only team...
that has white armor right now.
There's no fucking way.
No, no, no.
We're good.
We're not the only team.
Wait, why didn't we grab the fucking...
There's a team over here.
Why didn't we grab the cash right behind us?
I don't need any evil cash.
I'm blue, bitches!
That's all you, buddy.
I'm getting this cash for sure.
I'm going with Wig just in case we get...
I charge rifled him from 450 meters.
We love that for you.
Nice job, buddy.
I'm proud of you.
Alright, I'm out of here.
Don't worry, guys.
I am still gonna...
I'm on our roof.
fence this up.
Another team flew in there.
I'm gonna fence this up, guys.
I'm doing it.
We're playing in this building?
We gotta move up now.
We're gonna move up a little bit more.
We can't really move right now anyway because we're stuck.
We're stuck, Stepbro.
I wanna go through like launch, but...
Again, we don't have no evac towers.
I don't think we're ever gonna find evac towers.
I don't think so, guys.
I got one!
Go, Tempo!
I've always believed in you!
That's five stars!
Oh my God!
Tempo, Tempo, Tempo!
Tempo!
What the fuck are you doing?
Oh my God!
I'm safe.
I'm covering.
I got a kill.
It was on the bridge.
5 subs already?
That's 5 subs to 10.5 subs to me.
That's 10 subs.
That's insane.
We need to go command center.
I can try.
I can scan again.
Let's believe it.
Actually, yeah.
There's no way someone is going to shoot me, right?
There's no way.
I'm watching.
There's a team on south.
A team just fenced up south.
That's fine.
We can just play near for now.
I'm trying to find an evac.
Can I play in the middle up here?
Realistically, us getting out of the situation with that one is like...
Yeah, we need...
Unless everybody suddenly collides with each other.
Let me get the south team.
Alright.
Just in case.
We're good.
Nice job, Doki.
Look at me go.
I'm fencing.
I'm contributing to the team.
Hell yeah.
We're alive.
That's also a W.
I'll take NAW 20th all day, every day.
I'm being so serious.
Shit on, kid.
We're okay.
Everything will be fine.
No one's north.
No one's middle.
I just realized, bro.
My fucking... We all have...
Wait, you guys got purple and blue backpacks?
How did I end up with a white backpack?
I had a fucking wick.
Realistically, RV down here wouldn't be bad.
I just don't know how the fuck we get there.
How was I the one that ended up with the shittiest backpack out of all of you?
There's a team on bridge, isn't there?
Fuck me.
I'm gonna go away.
Yeah, the team on bridge is the one I got a knock on.
Can we get underneath this platform if we run?
Right now?
I mean, I don't know when else we're gonna do it.
I feel like...
I mean, it's very risky.
That's for sure.
It definitely is risky.
I don't think there's anyone on our right, though.
At least we have a rotational spot later.
I don't wanna play blue bins, because we're gonna go against the Gibraltar team who's gonna ult us.
I have all...
Wait, is this guy full-killed and not rez'd?
Yeah, full-killed.
Did you knock the team on the left?
Well, we don't know who exactly...
I killed a team on the bridge.
Yeah, but...
But they might have rez'd, because they have a rez beacon.
Is the rez beacon activated?
Yeah, it is.
It's activated.
I was gonna say, if we kill the team on the left, then we can go there.
We could...
Okay, but guys, we can scan again.
Lowkey could.
Well, actually, let's go back and do it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's really no negative.
This team's full-monus.
We're good.
They're gone.
Yeah, exactly.
We can do one last...
A Gibraltar!
Random Gibraltar on you!
Wait, wait, wait.
What the fuck did you do?
Oh, he's down.
He's downstairs.
Where, where, where?
He's running away.
Hit the beacon.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm going back up.
I got really scared.
Hit the beacon and run back to me immediately, because they're above you.
Okay, that is not very... I don't know.
I have a lot of confidence.
But here we go.
Nope.
One dropped down.
They went low ground, I think.
Yeah, they're low ground over here.
You're good.
You're...
We're still healthy.
I still don't know...
I did not see the Gibraltar at all.
We need to get underneath, brothers.
Wait, wait, wait.
We have no evac.
We have no... Gotta kill.
Oh, he got... Oh, he got... Oh, he got...
Oh, he gets up.
That's 10 subs each.
We need to move.
Okay, okay.
That's 10 subs each person.
Oh, come over here.
We're gonna come over here and play this.
Oh my god.
I have 12 nades.
Okay.
You're gonna set up your gen right here, Ducky.
Right here?
Okay, right now?
Actually, wait.
No, don't do that.
Don't do that.
I wanna see if we can get an RV.
If there's no one in an RV, we should get there underneath.
Tempo, you think you could, like, fuse all these guys up here on the bridge that we run for RV?
Yeah, let me find their wads and gen.
It's right here.
I can destroy it.
Okay, I'm gonna keep fencing.
I destroyed it.
Whoa.
Wait, there's a fuse queue somewhere.
Oh, Jesus.
No, they came from in front of us.
We're fine.
Yeah, we're fine.
We're still fucking fine.
We're good.
We're fine.
Yeah, we're good.
We're good.
We just need to get in zone more, which sucks.
Yeah, we are down.
We're just at the... I don't even think we're in zone.
Where's that scan coming from?
Wait, what the fuck?
Behind us.
Behind us?
Who the fuck is that?
Bro, I'm fucking setting this up.
Yeah, shut up.
Shut up.
They're pushing.
They are?
Like, 148 or 148.
I'm kidding.
I'm a left team.
I'm a shot from the team in front of us.
I'm here.
You're good.
Yeah.
I'm gonna scan again.
Okay, I'm good.
I'm good.
I'm good here.
I'm good now.
I don't see him.
Should be still over here.
I'm alright now, Swin.
You're good.
I think they want to push us in the back.
I'm checking.
I don't think they're gonna push us in the back.
Okay, they're not.
They're not.
They're just shooting at Jen.
I've scanned 12 seconds.
Okay.
Jen, go down.
It's okay.
Yeah, yeah.
It's pretty annoying, actually.
They're leaving.
They're gone.
Alright, we need to go to RB now.
We need to jump down.
This is really bad for us, actually.
Yeah, we don't have... Do you choose to ult with these guys or you don't have it anymore?
No, he doesn't.
I don't have it anymore.
Can you Q them?
Okay.
We're gonna move left.
Come left.
I only have that one Q.
Jump down.
We're good.
Come down.
We're so healthy.
We're so good.
Oh, we are not...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Protect that.
Oh, keep blocking that.
We're so healthy.
Yeah, you're good.
You're good.
We're not in zone, but we're so healthy.
I'm not in zone, but you're good.
You're good.
You're gonna play without me.
You're gonna die in zone?
Okay.
That is all I needed to know.
That's fine.
We're okay.
Noqo killed me.
What a piece of shit.
You guys are good, man.
I had a Moby on my death box, by the way.
Oh, wait.
Get it.
I can get it and raise him here.
Okay.
You probably could, actually.
You got this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get it.
Temple, I believe in you.
The zone doesn't hurt so much.
Did you get the...
He did not get the Moby.
Okay.
I'll get the Moby.
What the fuck?
I'm freezing my shirt.
We're good.
We're fine.
What?
Let me shoot these guys up here.
You rest.
I'll rest.
What the fuck did you do?
I'm looking up on the bridge.
I don't see them.
Okay.
I think we're okay, bro.
How are we not getting looked at right now?
What the fuck is going on?
Don't take this wig.
Don't cast it.
Free KP over here.
Don't do anything.
We're good.
I'm just kidding.
I'm so fucking good.
Don't worry.
Fences will protect us.
Alright.
We need to get in that corner.
They're fighting on bridge.
You guys should go to RV right now.
We were fighting bridge.
RV, RV, RV.
Let's go.
Go without me, go without me.
Go, go, go, go, go.
They're not watching.
They're watching now.
Someone is inside the RV.
What do you mean he's in the RV?
He's flashed.
RV is flashed.
He got in the RV.
Okay.
Great.
We have a strat here though.
We have a strat.
One sec.
We're gonna get in this corner over here, Celan, okay?
You still have your mobi if you loot your body.
I didn't loot it.
He didn't loot his spot.
I couldn't loot anything, damn.
Wait, does that guy have a body?
No.
Oh, no.
No, no, no, no.
Okay, wait, Celan, we have a play.
I'm not even kidding.
We have a play.
Okay?
We're gonna get into this corner.
Come here.
Okay.
Come, come, come, come, come.
Come to me.
I don't know if I want to, but no.
Oh, we're so good.
We're healthy.
Are you sure?
That's a good placement.
Yes, yes, yes, come here, come here.
Trust us.
Okay, okay, okay.
I might die now because I hesitated.
Oh, my God.
Don't be a little bitch, you Celan.
I hesitated.
Movement.
There's no way.
There's no way there was a full team.
It didn't matter.
There was a full team running at us.
But no, they were on the other side of the rock.
If we get there, we're vibing.
Oh, my God.
There's even full teams.
Not a single evac.
What are we supposed to do?
It's okay.
We got three kills because of tempo.
We got three kills.
We got four points.
Four points.
I'll take...
Four points is actually not bad.
Actually...
Four points is like the tenth place area.
We're good.
And also, no stand, no evac.
Yeah, it's pretty good.
Of course, I got a fucking pyro howl.
Fuck me, man.
Tempo, go over there and hold his PC hostage right now.
Yeah, Tempo, run in there, bro, and summon his monitor immediately.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Run over there, take his monitor, show it on stream, and give Hal a message.
Yeah.
Snipe down, killed you, and Hal.
I got a tag team, bro.
I got Eiffel Towered by the fucking XTSM.
Guys, we got four kills, and we didn't die 20th.
That's all that matters.
I'm not gonna lie.
That was pretty good.
Yeah, that was pretty good with the situation we were in.
Yeah, that situation was pretty terrible.
Yeah, that was pretty terrible.
Pretty fucking terrible.
I'm not gonna lie.
I feel like that's what we say every time.
We're like, that was really bad for us, but we did kinda good.
That's what we say.
That's like our motto.
Okay, Tempo, how many kills you got?
We got a lot.
He got two kills, so that's 10 subs each.
Fuck me.
Yeah.
Pay up.
Oh, shit.
I'm torched.
Oh my god, my moderator's still alive.
W.
Your moderator is...
Yeah, he is.
Alucard is the coach.
Okay, if he has a high placement, then I'm torched.
If so, give us some of his prize winnings.
Alright, I'm back.
That is the key.
Okay, that's how it works, we don't pay him to be my mod.
But I still take a percentage of his win.
Yeah.
Our money now.
100%.
That's exactly how Twitch works.
Yeah.
Lowkey.
We're still alive.
Oh, sweet.
Still alive, of course.
And the prize is COC Clan just going crazy.
Fuck.
This is so funny.
Only an enemy is dead.
Oh, no one's dead.
I think if we had zone in any way, we definitely would have lived longer.
Oh no, if we had zone, we could have went to Lava Siphon, took the loot, you know what I mean?
Yeah, we would have been so healthy.
I wanted to get that RV pretty bad.
We got that RV earlier where we could have killed an RV.
We sort of lost somebody.
Wait, Eroko!
He came out of the RV solo!
Bro, I thought 4-2 was there!
I didn't realize anyone was there and I'm just nading the bridge.
And then, Eroko just comes out and then I have to mark him.
Bro, the guy was so confident that I thought it was a full team so I went to the side.
No, I mean we did.
We obviously did a good job.
We got in there and we killed him.
We could have died.
Realistically, I should have got a kill on the Gibraltar up top too.
I almost one-closed him for like a thousand levels.
That was crazy.
Probably the only time I'll have a good shot today.
It's okay.
This is our peak, guys.
This is the best gameplay you're going to see out of all of us.
This is the start of the damage.
We get plus one kill after every game.
Yeah, there's no way we can beat that.
Nothing kills game six.
There's no way we can be last because we already started out strong with kills.
I was hoping someone would mis-pick a legend and they'd get minus five and then they'd get like bottom five and then their scoreboard is just negative.
Did anyone mis-pick a legend?
There must have been one person.
They said they were going to restart if they...
Bro, what the fuck, babies?
Funny teams up, 59 players alive.
Okay, nice.
I mean, not nice.
Not nice.
They're already two people over advantage.
It's called survival of the fittest.
We were able to...
We were able to connect.
We were able to evolve to what we are.
We didn't survive the fittest.
I did not do this tournament so Imperial Howl can make more money.
Why the fuck did you...
You should have not invited him.
That would go so well.
Thank God.
We'll take second place.
Alright, wait, wait.
Okay.
It's like everybody's invited except for Hal.
That was like... having those comps were kind of fun.
I kind of like seeing the legend numbers.
That was a good time.
Yeah.
I can't believe I got hit with a sentinel and then a repeater when I died like that.
That was so fast.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I feel like even if I trusted you, Wig, we would have still died.
Oh, no, no.
I don't know.
Even if I trusted you and we ran at the same time, we still...
You would have still died.
I don't know because I got...
Yeah, probably.
Yeah.
No, no.
They were already heading towards you.
They were...
Yeah.
Hal scanning a duo is just...
It's GG's.
I think he just literally started foaming out of his mouth.
He was so ready for it.
He scans us.
He just swipes us for sure.
Damn you, Tempo.
My God.
It's fucking awesome.
I'm so happy.
Who was charged rifle?
Oh,
it was me.
Oh my God.
I'm gonna take credit.
Oh no.
Peep got DC'd?
Fuck, that sucks.
We didn't restart?
Oh.
Did I ask for a non-mode or does it not matter?
Oh, it doesn't really matter.
No, no.
Don't ask for a...
No, wait, wait.
Don't ask for...
It'd be more fun.
It'd be really bad.
It's gonna make me really mad.
I need to go to their channels and clip them raging.
Oh my god.
I need to know who I'm killing.
His little YouTube compilation.
He's gonna make the pros rage at me.
Apex Legends compilation.
You won't believe which pro got angry at me.
Yeah, I'm gonna help you with the clickbait titles.
You're so good at that.
Wait, what do we...
Do we get our subs?
Bang, Wraith, Octane, Valk, Seer, Cat, Newcastle, Conduit.
Oh, they announced it?
Okay.
Oh, I can do Catalyst.
I'll do the controller.
Oh wait, they announced the Legends?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bang, Wraith, Octane, Valk, Seer, Newcastle, and Conduit.
Because Doki's going Cat.
Yeah.
We have Valk!
I mean, I mean, wait, wait, wait.
That means you can take Octane and I'll take Valk.
Do we trust Temple or Valk?
This is where I'm supposed to think, right?
Wait, who played Valk when we played last time?
That was me.
You played Watson and Doki played...
Well, yeah, Doki played...
What did I play?
Bang, Bang.
Bang?
Oh yeah, but Bang's nerfed, right?
Yeah, she, I mean, yeah, she's not bad though.
Wait, isn't like the Bang smoke something something?
You said two words and then the words that mattered was not there.
Well, something changed.
I just don't know what the something was, okay?
A lot of things changed, Temple.
You gotta be more specific here.
Alright, my brain is telling me I should play Valk but my heart's saying Octane.
You should listen to your brain.
The times you've listened to your heart.
Oh, you're still right.
My heart told me to pick you guys and my brain was like, what the fuck are you doing?
So maybe I should have listened to my brain in that situation.
Yeah.
So in this situation...
We're not last place.
Just so you know, your heart picked us.
You're right.
My heart didn't pick you guys, which is the right choice.
So I'm going Octane next game.
Who are you guys playing?
Okay, then I'll take Valk.
Okay.
Wait, next game.
Yeah, so we can play.
And then I'll do Catalyst.
Yeah, you can do Cat, Bang, whoever you're comfortable with.
All right.
I'll do Cat.
We need zone readers.
Yeah, this could be a good zone.
When I am the rational one in this team, that's when you know things are bad.
Oh, wait, my Valk has a... Oh, no, wait, no, it's the challenges.
My Valk is locked.
Wait, has Wake... Tempo, did Wake give you 10 subs yet?
No, I'll do it after.
Oh, okay.
Oh, we stacked them up.
We're going to stack 100.
Every time you get a kill, it's a plus five.
Just remind me.
I'll remember that.
Okay.
Tempo, he's going to literally fund your lifestyle.
Wait, what map are we on?
We're on Storm Point.
Storm Point.
Storm Point?
Okay.
Storm Point is blue, right?
Storm Point, we're going Command.
So can we get Valk all the way out of that, right?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, we're good, guys.
We're so good.
We're so healthy.
I was trying to pick my Valk.
Oh, sorry.
My skin.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I need to pick my skins.
Okay.
You're right.
I need to rearrange my badges.
Oh, wait.
My Valk badge.
Yeah.
My tribal badge on.
I was going to play...
I already forgot what I was playing.
Catalyst.
Yes.
Banner.
Don't worry.
I'm going to make sure everybody knows what rank I'm in.
I just want you to know I have zero kills on Catalyst.
Yeah.
I think I also have zero.
Wait a minute!
Wait wait wait wait wait wait.
I was too busy with Jeb Burton.
What did you just say?
I have zero kills on Kat.
Zero Kat kills.
And you chose Kat over Ben?
Yeah.
What is Kat's passive?
She can...
lock doors.
Oh wait no that's a door.
Nevermind.
She can throw out the spikes.
She can lock the doors.
Lock the doors is crazy.
Yeah.
I mean technically it's locking doors.
And then she can...
She can put up a wall.
And...
And she looks...
She looks slay while doing it.
She does look slay.
To be honest.
I'm so happy Trick2G is playing bro.
I used to watch Trick2G like everyday.
In League.
When I was an avid League player and I wanted to fucking...
cry everyday.
That's who I watched.
Oh yeah that's what I was going to say.
You played League.
I was going to say like are you okay?
Are you okay?
Two years playing.
Silver 2 Peak.
Silver 2 Peak?
Yeah.
You're like that...
Oh wait.
I don't know if I can say it.
You're like that one guy that was like silver or something.
And he played League his whole career.
And then...
And then he tried to own an esport org.
You know that guy.
Sam Baikman Fried?
Yeah the crypto dude?
He just got 25 years in jail.
Yeah I saw that.
This is true we can talk about it because Tempo is here.
Oh true.
That's true.
What was the fucking code again?
FTX?
FTX yeah.
Hey Tempo.
What was it called again?
Tempo you remember that...
That coin that had a deal with TSM?
That promised you guys like 200 million dollars?
That guy.
The one that's been like apparently like bronze or whatever after 10 years of League.
So then he decided to own an esport org.
That guy.
Well it's a good thing we can talk about it.
Yeah he should be able to openly talk about this.
You know?
It's for KTempo.
That whole shit is actually crazy.
Yeah I'm surprised.
Like I'm surprised he got away.
He almost got away with it.
Until he got 25 years in prison.
I don't even know that's enough though.
That was like the biggest heist ever.
Yeah he almost got away with it too.
He was just meddling kids.
I'm trying to pull that out again.
35 million.
35 years.
Yeah he made an entire esport org to change their fucking name.
Yeah and he also paid off a fucking um...
There's another... there's like a basketball team I think.
Oh yeah!
With crypto!
Yeah yeah yeah.
Crazy.
That's actually insane.
He did everything with that money.
He did everything with that money to actually do what he was supposed to do.
I'm back guys.
Yeah oh you missed that whole thing huh?
You missed our whole thing.
We're in like 9th place.
We're top 10!
We're like tied for 9th.
There's like 5 people with 4 points.
Nice.
We got this.
Alright wait what?
What?
I was like they started showing the standings and I was so invested to see where we were.
You were so invested.
I completely zoned out.
That's good.
We were talking really great about TSM.
Oh okay.
Yeah.
That's good.
Yeah don't worry.
We're hyping TSM up.
So you won't get fired.
Never.
We will never do that.
About that?
Hello?
Something you didn't tell us or what?
Whoa.
Temple.
Temple what happened?
Can I sleep on your couch?
I told you bro.
Lan my couch is yours.
I got you a blanket.
I got you on warm milk at night if you need.
Like whatever you want bro I'm down.
Bro was this before us?
Morning juice box and everything.
You'll actually be treated like a king in my apartment.
Holy shit.
When Vaxcon slept over he didn't have a blanket.
He had to use one of the pillows as a blanket.
I'm taking all your juice.
Wait are they kicking you out of the house?
No.
This is for right or I was about to say this is for Twitch rivals.
Oh.
Are you going to LAN?
No.
Wait is that in LA?
Yeah.
What date is it?
What is it?
May 2nd.
Okay that's like a far.
I still have time to think about it.
When am I going to be on your fucking B stream?
When can I roll up?
Yeah literally roll up on an iPad?
Yeah roll up on an iPad.
You got to actually buy one of those.
No Tempo is going to buy it for me.
Huh?
The most broke one out of the three?
I thought you had a plan.
Don't you have a million subs on YouTube?
No no no no no no no no.
No no no I'm not a million.
I'm not a million.
I'm like I'm a poor.
I'm very tiny.
I'm a very tiny streamer.
I just started a month ago guys.
I just started a month ago.
Oh so true.
You're brand new to this.
I charge up a little sweet in the side of the head for 140.
I'm just a natural entertainer.
Good for you.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
He typed it not me.
I thought you had the setup already.
Because you were going to do it on last LAN.
What happened?
I didn't buy it.
I didn't buy the roller coaster thing.
Of course you didn't buy it.
You didn't buy it?
You literally told me like oh TSA won't let me do it.
I have the iPad.
Yes he has the iPad.
I have the tablet.
I need the rolling thingy with the wheels.
I need connections with the A staff.
Let me go talk to Chen.
We can literally convince them.
Because it's in LA instead of London.
We don't have to get a plane.
We can return it to the respawn.
Exactly.
And then they can reuse it every time I want to butt in.
Oh.
You can playtest with the rolling iPad.
No we cannot.
She's going to go straight into me.
Terrorize all the staff that are working.
No I'm just...
We need to pay attention here.
We might be conned guys.
We might be conned?
Maybe.
I don't know.
We have no beacon.
Again?
What the fuck is the point of this?
We have no beacon character.
Of course we have no beacon.
We didn't pick a control character.
We're just rolling.
Wait.
No I mean a map scan.
Oh wait.
Wait.
No I'm Katniss.
Katniss can scan maps.
You're literally the fucking casting.
I'm watching.
You watch so many Apex streams that you still don't know who's the controller.
I forgot you were on Tat bro.
I forgot.
Oh my gosh.
We have the...
Don't you forget it.
I'm so confused.
I have a jump tower.
Guys.
We're so set.
On me.
I told you I knew it.
We're actually getting contested?
No way I'm getting contested in my own tournament.
Yeah.
What the fuck.
They saw us.
I see one all the way up there.
We want to get height.
That's the problem here.
Can we not take this now?
No I don't think we can.
They're covering it.
Bro they're taking it.
Right now.
Your audio.
My audio is back on.
You had no audio?
Bro.
Where is someone we can rotate to that has it?
I forgot I lowered my old char...
You didn't ping the charge.
I'm sorry I was a little bit confluxed.
Here he is at 6x.
Oh 6x.
They're leaving.
Oh I'm rich.
Alright I don't have any.
They're leaving.
We're going to go over to where they were and we're going to go on the zip line again.
We want to take height.
We definitely do.
I'm right behind you.
If anything happens.
That's fine thank you.
If anything happens we can not craft you because we don't have that.
Wait what?
They're still here.
Did they shoot you Tempo?
They shot you?
They're pushing this.
Go back.
We don't want to fight this.
Just leave.
Yeah.
Going through this door then?
I'm going to lock the door.
I just don't know if this zone is going this way and we're going to get ran at.
Because this zone actually looks like it could be.
Let's take this house to our right side right now.
Alright.
I'd rather just be safe.
And just go to wall later.
We can grab the...
The cash thing after.
Yeah I'm down.
Okay guys I haven't played Catalyst in a while.
So how many spikes can I do?
Back back back.
Should we go to the bottom one?
Yeah just go down.
I'm heading down.
We're so messy.
Oh shit I just went straight up.
No don't die there please.
We're going to play for here right now and see what goes on.
We got the Evo cash here as well.
Suck it.
Just pay attention there's definitely someone that could be posting up coming at us.
I'm locking the door.
Yeah yeah just set up right now.
We're getting hoed right now.
I'm pretty hard.
And I'm locking this door.
These people don't like us apparently.
Sucks.
I am like not confident right now.
We got the Evo cash right?
I'm so confident.
Actually we're not in like a bad spot regardless of where the sound goes.
What about our loot?
We can go over to wall after this and just probably get Evo cash.
I don't see someone was shooting us from here but I don't see them anywhere.
I don't know either.
I have like no long range so I'm just going to...
Oh there's a longbow here for anybody.
I would take that ammo.
I'm going to run this then for long range.
I dropped a vault if anyone wants to.
I have a vault already.
This team is not staying on the height of that building which is making me think it's not going here.
Oh wait someone just landed on top.
Yes, maybe they think it is going over there which is pretty good.
I think we just stay in this house for now.
Yeah let's just not waste any loot because we're very poor.
Don't have a lot of it.
Yeah we're free.
We're pretty poor right now.
Would anyone kind of like to donate loot to us?
Please we need it.
Please.
If anybody stream sniping us.
Wait Doki do you have Q's at all?
Yeah.
Can you try to put one on the window just for the peek?
Oh yeah sure.
I think you can.
Wait the team on height is shooting someone that's going this way.
Alright.
That's not great.
Is that alright?
Yeah for visual clutter it doesn't matter.
They just dropped back down to...
They're not on height anymore.
I'm stressed.
Are you stressed out about?
We have good position.
We should loot but like as long as they don't come in and kill us.
I'm covering a cell.
Yeah only problem is we're just triple wiped.
Someone shoots that thing and I'm like ooo.
Okay then just don't get shot.
We're in the cure packs can't we skin them?
I tried I didn't look quick enough I'm an idiot.
Oh wait they're fighting in cascades.
That's fine.
Yeah yeah try to farm some shit.
Yeah yeah yeah you farm for us we're just gonna look be here.
Yeah you get your shield up buddy.
I have 4 cells.
Okay I have some here.
Oh my god do you guys remember the strat that we were supposed to do last time?
I have 2 beds.
Where like uh you know remember the one where we let tempo drop wherever the fuck he wants and then...
Oh my god.
I do remember that one.
We never did that strat.
We did that so bad.
We got last game today.
We did that.
Yeah tempo chopper.
Oh shit he's in that room.
Of course.
Of course he is.
On roof we're dead here.
We're so dead.
We need to go wall slot.
I'm leaving I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
We should have made tempo.
Were you on top of the building tempo?
Yeah he was by the way.
Okay no idea I'm here.
I'm dead.
Yes it doesn't matter.
Drop got me.
They're sending us.
They're pushing us.
You should have ran.
You shouldn't have been a hero.
Oh my god.
We got 20 in tempo.
Tempo we got.
Tempo man.
We got last tempo.
Tempo.
Wait we're not center zone.
Oh probably.
In that zone we were.
Tempo.
We actually got 20.
I know.
Does this game hate us?
Okay what if like in our third game.
We let tempo land.
We let tempo go wherever the fuck he wants.
No cause no no.
Cause this next game is Olympus.
We have phase drivers.
That's what you said about last game.
We have infinite balls.
But what if we get contested one though.
No.
Oh we might get contested.
I mean it's cause people see our names.
Like yo.
Oh fuck.
We do not want to fight that guy.
I thought you said we had good feeling.
I'm working on my own tournament dude.
What's going on.
Let me go find some.
Is there anyone that's free tempo?
Olympus.
I can't believe it.
That was so tough dude.
Super unfortunate.
Wait this is why you don't follow your heart.
I mean.
Why am I getting contested at command center bro.
You followed your heart.
And then we got 20 in place.
And we go command center no beacon.
And then we got contested.
My strategy is just fucked out the window there.
Because the whole point is I wanted to get beacon.
Then valko will come up there so we don't have to shoot for the rest of the game.
We just know exactly where to go.
Cause tempo is sitting on top of roofs.
Yeah.
With his back.
No comment.
Very bottom.
I was shooting someone.
I was shooting cascades.
And then I don't know where those guys came from.
They were in the house next to us.
Alright we'll shoot at these guys.
I found a map.
Did we get zero points?
No.
Yes we were 20.
I wasn't sure if we got a kill or not.
Or if tempo worked some magic with that charge rifle.
I wasn't sure.
Get revenge.
No one is good.
Tempo what's free?
What's free for the next map?
We are moving on.
Remember like a goldfish.
What's free?
Where is the laces?
Do we have anything?
Is there...
We should...
Oh my god.
I have an idea.
If there's no...
If there's no spot free.
We see who is the 20th place team.
And we land on them.
That's us.
No I meant overall.
Overall.
Is that fucked up?
That's not fucked up right?
Dude we are weak and we are playing on the weaker.
That's fair as fuck.
It's strategy.
If people can do that in pro league and fuck over other teams.
We can too.
That's...
There's no rules against doing that.
Against sabotaging other teams.
Yup.
Okay so we just need to find out.
Who is overall 20th place.
And then take their...
Then take their POI.
I...
I don't know if we can even be 20th place.
There's no way.
I think we are the 20th.
In terms of gun skill.
No no.
I think we are the 10th place.
There's one open POI.
Turbine.
Oh that's good.
Say turbine in chat please.
Or guys.
Or we can get 3 points.
And land on the 20th team overall.
But here's the thing.
If we lose the 20th place team.
What the fuck are we gonna do?
Then we're the 20th place team.
And then we become the 20th place team.
Oh my gosh.
Do you not believe in us?
I believe in...
Okay do you not believe in me?
Let's not add tempo into the equation.
No no I believe in you.
You are a platform player.
I'm pretty good for a platform player.
You know if you think about it.
For a platform player.
I'm pretty good.
If we get tempo not to die.
We're good to go.
That's true.
Tempo got us 2 points last game.
That's the thing.
We need him to be alive to farm points for us.
We just need a...
I'm confused.
You know why that happened?
Because I was on Valk and I was like.
I can fly and then I flew to the roof.
This is what...
If I was any other legend.
I would not have been able to make it up on the roof.
And I would be like.
This is why you never listen to your heart.
I was trying to be a good teammate.
He was so excited to play Valk.
I don't know what to say.
To be a good teammate.
You seemed like you were like.
I want to play Valk.
No because he wanted you to play Octane.
Tempo was the one that was trying to be a good teammate.
Realistically.
Realistically we want to be honest here.
Tempo should be playing the controller characters.
Okay.
I'll take all the controllers.
Unless there is a fuse.
Okay.
Tell them not to add it.
Put fuse in.
Tell them to remove all fuses.
From now on.
Some of my chat says.
You realize that Doki still has zero kills on cat.
You still have zero kills on cat after that game.
Zero kills on cat.
Yeah dude.
Keeping that tradition.
Less than 100 kills on cat.
We are so torched.
Why are there so many teams alive still?
I don't know.
That's because we died pretty early.
Yeah that's because.
We didn't even get the Valk ulti that game.
We didn't even get any ulti.
Guys 20th place in my own tournament is crazy.
Yeah.
We have to get at least 19th in that game.
We have to.
Please.
We are not improving.
No one is contesting next game.
Guys.
That's good.
That's already one thing we don't have to worry about.
That's true.
That also means no one is going to die to Nia.
We should tell everybody.
We should tell everybody what our skins are.
So they won't run at us.
Then we will give them someone else's skin.
That is so true.
What is this team skins?
Yellow bang.
I am now a yellow bang.
I will play yellow skins.
Or bright pink.
We are giving people wrong...
Wait.
What map are we playing on?
We are giving people other people's skin colors.
My mom in the chat said I am back.
What is happening?
Mom we just got 20th place.
No you could have lied.
Mom we got first.
We got first last game.
We were doing so well that EA staff told us to sit this one out.
So other people can have a chance.
We are watch partying from inside the game now.
I want to say right now this is better than international scrims quality.
14 teams alive on board.
We have 14 teams alive after 12 seconds of the first game.
People don't get money from scrims.
Of course this is better.
You are so right.
Money changes everything.
Even if they did.
Not for us though.
There is not change anything for us.
We are literally content.
No Temple you should start giving vouchers for your scrims.
So people take it more seriously.
Like a $5 coupon for something.
A $5 coupon?
We will gift you 5 subs if you survive.
That's so true.
That's how we should do the payout.
Yeah.
Instead of 4 world placements.
5.
Pass round 3.
For every round you survive.
Your team earns extra money.
Like I said.
5 subs per person.
That will be financed by WIG.
Yeah.
Make the bank account for everybody.
But WIG will give you better quality scrims.
Which means better.
More viewers.
More viewers in general.
Which means more income in general.
So in the end.
You are going to gain money.
You are so smart.
Viewers would want to watch better scrims.
Because the scrims will be longer too.
Yeah.
And then you can run as many ads as you want.
Sorry guys.
I'm going to run ads now.
Doki has a fascination with me spending money.
She is like.
Listen.
When Kempo gets these kills.
You just drop like 600 bucks each.
It's not that big of a deal.
It's motivation.
Money motivates people.
It's true.
Look at right now.
Look at the quality of this tournament.
It's the most motivated I've seen snipe down in a very long time.
You.
Whoa.
Him not being relegated.
Him being relegated probably didn't help.
He's playing like he's 10 years younger right now.
Oh yeah.
And he dies.
And he just died.
And he gets beeped across the fucking map.
Dude.
You have to stay regulated.
There is no fucking way.
You just actually VTuber cursed him so hard.
You're the one that mentioned his name first.
What do you mean?
I was talking about getting money motivation.
But you're here.
You're here.
I'm here.
I give the extra curse.
Agreed.
There's got to be something along with VTubers and curses.
They don't make sense.
No I think casters give a better curse than VTubers.
I will agree that I definitely give a harder curse.
Yeah.
For sure.
I agree with that one.
Holy shit.
This is a hard zone.
I'm going to be honest guys.
I'm kind of happy we died.
What do you mean?
You're happy that we died 20th?
Yeah a little bit.
We would have been on that house on the left side.
We could have Valked over there and got the house.
That would have been us.
I think the tempo is just a boss for that.
Just sitting on top of a roof like that is crazy.
Yeah with white armor.
That was actually crazy.
Like all confidence white armor.
Did you not think you were on white armor?
I don't think it would help.
I mean I don't think it would help.
He was dead regardless.
If I had blue I would have been alive.
You were literally dead and he still charged rightfully.
Tempo your reaction time on that was crazy.
How do you know?
You didn't see anything.
I looked up and you were still in the same spot.
You were still standing still when you were getting shot.
What do you mean?
I don't know what you are talking about.
I'm talking about you Tempo.
Jersey is off.
Are you taking off your shirt right now?
I'm ready.
The day I stop playing is the day Tempo plays in a tournament shirtless.
He is shirtless right now.
Look at this.
Is that Toss?
Can you play with your titty's out?
No it feels like...
You know those like nipple stickers?
That they...
On Twitch people who do it on Twitch for body paint.
Pasties.
How do you know the name of that?
I've been doing it.
I've been knowing things.
How do you know their names?
I used to watch makeup tutorials when I was younger.
Really?
Yeah I was interested in makeup for a while.
Oh shit.
Do you wear pasties on your nips?
No I do not wear pasties.
Why not?
I'm fucking naked bro.
Bro but you had a fascination.
No I was just interested with makeup.
I was like oh these people are good at it.
Wait how many...
Okay if you put that as a...
As a goal.
What to wear pasties on street?
There is not a single goal that would get me shirtless with nipple tassels.
I don't know how to fucking feel.
No not like tassels but like just cover it as if you have no nipples.
I would actually rather have tassels than any of those you know.
Than no nipples?
Wait wait why would you not want to be nippleless?
I don't want to see what I look like like that.
Oh my god someone said you can make them spin.
That's what I'm saying.
Alright we're back.
What do you mean we're back?
We've been here the whole time.
I want to go grab some stuff.
Wait are you actually shirtless right now?
No.
Bro no balls.
No balls is crazy.
No.
Hey wait if...
Oh no he's dead.
Oh god who's winning just tell me who is winning.
Well not Drops team.
We just saw him got mowed down there.
He got rocked.
We gotta make sure I'm anonymous next game.
Bye.
This is more fun.
Yeah it is.
Of course you did.
Of course.
Wait so you wouldn't...
You wouldn't wear...
Why wouldn't you wear Pacey's?
Why are you afraid of being like nippleless?
I don't understand Wig.
I just don't want to see what I look like without...
I don't know I'm just...
I'm down but I'm trying to do it on stream.
I'm trying to be like...
No nipples on stream.
I'm not even trying to show my nipples on stream.
But it's not against TOS.
No I like fully understand it's not against TOS.
It's just like I'm not trying to show my nipples.
But you won't be showing it.
Because it won't be seen.
Drops why...
Bro why did you do that to poor tempo?
Man was scoped in...
499, 9 times...
Charge Rifling.
Bro people...
Your chat wants it.
They want that content.
Of course my chat wants it.
They see me as a piece of meat.
I bend over to turn my Christmas tree on and it's just non-stop fucking comments.
Wait is that why you have a Christmas tree on?
So you can make an excuse to bend over?
No I should get a whiteboard though.
Oh you should.
Every time like...
You use it to put the scores down for scrims.
So every time you're like...
Oh this team won.
You can bend...
You can turn it around.
Oh look at these winners.
Look at all these scrim winners.
That's content right there.
That is 100% content.
I'm asking Drop how bad your reaction time was.
Yo the game doesn't count okay?
Because anonymous zone was supposed to happen but it didn't.
So the whole game is...
Oh my god yes.
Tell them right now.
If pro league can do that we can too.
It's your tournament.
The game doesn't count because anonymous mode was not on.
Yeah.
Wait tell them that right now.
Alrighty.
What am I telling them?
Tell them that because anonymous mode was not on when you told them to tell them on.
It doesn't count.
This game is wiped off.
For sure.
I think they're totally going to listen to me after they've paid for everyone to be there for a certain amount of hours.
No I'll just...
I mean obviously I think Doki's right.
I'll just put another...
I'll put like $20,000 of my own money into this.
Exactly.
Yeah exactly.
And then you can make it back by having a whiteboard.
All you need to do is run one ad.
You're a genius.
One ad and you break even.
One ad $20,000.
You're like maybe two ads.
New legends.
Maybe two ads.
Ash Bullish.
Top Finder.
Crypto Vantage.
Caustic Lifeline.
Art Machine.
Obviously Tempo's Caustic.
Alright.
We're on...
Oh Olympus.
Olympus.
Yeah.
I need a white.
Alright.
I mean to be fair the other ones are just whatever you're comfortable with Doki.
I'm down with anything.
Honestly.
I mean we could do Lifeline just to crack people if Tempo dies.
Or wait no actually if Wig dies.
Because you're the...
You're gonna be taking most of the hits.
I should probably play Path for rotational purposes.
I'll play Path for our rotations.
Zip lines and stuff.
I'll play Lifeline for the crafter.
Okay.
You cool with that?
Yeah I'm cool with that.
Alright let me change my skin and badges.
We're so locked in guys.
We're gonna get a beacon and turbine.
Cause this map...
Does not have a beacon.
Alright.
Okay Lifeline.
No I need therapy after Tempo today.
That's my dog.
Alright.
I went to therapy once.
I did too.
Only once?
Yeah it's way more.
Both of you guys should go more than once.
Cause you went once of course it didn't work out.
It was never gonna work out.
You don't know that.
You need to find the right therapist.
And the issues are impossible.
Woah.
What issues?
Issues are impossible.
Okay you know what Tempo?
Trauma dump on us right now.
You're a sociopath.
Wait really?
Okay I was gonna feel like...
Holy shit.
And you were a teacher.
I was gonna move around children.
You think sweet comes with a turbine just to go with it?
No wait.
That's why I was...
That's why I...
Wait.
Teacher thing turned me into one.
That's the way.
No again.
Children can't turn you into a sociopath.
You're...
What is the 340...
If we get contested at...
If we get contested at turbine we're so choked guys.
Wait.
So we'll late drop turbine?
Cause if someone tries to contest us turbine it means another POI is open.
Cause there's one team...
Yeah there's one team per POI right now.
Okay.
We'll just late drop and if someone contests us...
We'll destroy a 2009 their PC.
Alright.
No one's doing turbine I don't think.
There's no one doing turbine.
Yeah so we're fine.
If someone swerves.
Yeah.
Guys.
Guys we...wait.
We should make a team paranoid.
Who's like the 20th team overall?
And what is the POI?
We'll just pretend we're going somewhere else.
Are we 20th?
Yeah yeah yeah.
No no no.
I wanna make a team...
I wanna make a team paranoid by saying we're landing on their POI.
So you think they're getting contested.
Who's last right now?
No wait.
No that's 5 head cause then someone will try and kill us off drop and then...
Yeah that's why.
And then there's three teams.
Exactly.
And then they'll really be contesting the other team.
Yeah that's why I'm big braining this right now.
Who's the 20th team and what's the POI?
I'm looking at the leaderboard.
I mean I'm waiting for the leaderboard to get updated.
Hawaii.
Website.
Guys I'm gonna be honest.
Can I say a statement that we might not like here?
Okay.
Wait what is it?
I did not believe in us for Challenger Circuit at all.
And I'm gonna be honest.
Oh thank god you said that.
Wait a minute.
I still don't believe in us less.
I'm glad you said it.
Because I don't.
We're gonna be going against...
We're against makeshift teams right now.
Okay.
When we go to Challengers we're gonna be against teams that have been playing together for a little bit.
Yeah and that's why.
We've been scrimming and everything.
But people who are playing on a touchpad that have been playing together are still not gonna be able to hit anything.
So you think these people are playing on iPads in Challengers?
They're on the Switch.
They joined the Challengers.
Oh no no.
Not that they're actually playing on a Switch.
But they might as well be playing on a Switch.
They can't hit anything.
Oh I see.
Yeah yeah yeah.
They're uploading the scores right now.
Where?
I think we're last.
That's so sad.
We have four points.
We have to be last.
Don't say that.
There's like ten teams below us.
If you find the scores over here.
I already looked.
Please select final results.
Don't say that.
There has to be a team.
Team more?
Team more buts.
It's not updated yet.
They haven't uploaded the score.
Okay let's just look at the current last place team.
And say their POI.
Oh final results.
I see.
Yeah yeah.
It's not uploaded.
How the fuck?
Timmy is last place right now.
Yeah we're in ninth.
No not yet.
That's round one.
There's three teams with zero points.
It's Timmy, WeThePeople, and Kian.
Okay.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Where are they landing?
I'm going to look at where they're landing.
Timmy was landing phase.
Kian's team is really good.
I'm not trying to land on them.
Who's Kian's team?
Terminal.
Him and Khan.
Is Terminal on...
Is Terminal the third map?
Wait what's their third map?
Terminal the third map, Donkey?
I know this is the drop spot.
She's more confused than I am.
We're playing Olympus, Donkey.
I was going to say is Terminal in Olympus?
Okay we're landing in Terminal.
I was going to say we're landing in Terminal.
What if they land on Turbine now?
Thinking we're going Terminal.
No they won't.
Then we go Terminal.
I said we're landing Terminal.
There's no way.
If they do that we're fucked.
They're the last place.
Oh wait they have Kai.
Never mind.
I'm scared.
They have Control.
I'm the last place.
We just got back to Usu.
I have no idea how they're last.
They're good.
Wait they're not.
It's not updated yet though.
And they have a Control player too.
No no no.
They're staying.
They're staying Terminal.
And you die to us in Terminal.
Law.
I'm just...
I'm baiting him.
I'm baiting him right now.
Okay.
So hopefully Sweet goes over there.
And kills Kai.
And then we'll get 19.
We're so fucked.
I'm landing on you.
Hey Wig great.
Peep just decent.
Dude, the game.
No, no, no.
Sorry, sorry.
Bro, what a...
You're such a snitch, Wig.
Wig the vibes were high until Tempo got his head taken off.
I rewatched.
Rewatched what?
He rewatched the fucking clip.
He re-hacked a 20-second clip.
10 seconds after?
Bro, what the fuck, Devo?
How do you react twice?
It wasn't 20 seconds, okay?
It was like 10.
How does that make it better?
10 seconds makes this better.
That is very fast.
10 seconds reaction time.
Did you have a 6 times or a 4 to 8?
I got a 6.
Yeah, 6.
It's not my fault.
It's a 6x.
Yeah, it's a scope.
Guys, it's not his fault, guys.
Don't worry, we'll make it back.
Alright, let's get to 15 points.
So we need what, 11?
11 is so doable, guys.
11 points?
We need 6 kills in fourth place.
Yeah, yeah.
We need a beacon and we need a shield.
We need an evac tower.
I had an evac tower, too!
You did?
Yeah, I told you guys!
I know, but we got stuck on command, bro.
How did they get into command if we went in the middle?
Because they went frontside.
I think they thought that no one was there, so they just went in the front.
Because we went through the butthole.
Yeah.
They might not come back next one.
Oh, right, we're playing there again.
Wait, we have somebody missing on the far right.
Wait, that means that I can see where in Stormpoint is it.
Who said that sucks, Star?
I just got jury duty, have fun, man.
Are you supposed to go to jury duty, like, yearly?
No, you can pretend.
You get RNG'd for jury duty.
Yeah, you get RNG'd for jury duty and then you can tell them that you're not competent enough to be a...
Yeah, just say you're stupid and...
I would do that 100%.
Okay.
Just be like...
What if you could, like, put on, like, a really crazy intense big case?
That would be scary.
That's why you don't take the case.
No, no, that's why you take it.
That's why you take it and then you manipulate everyone.
No, okay, here's how to get out of, like, jury duty.
Okay, as a... not an American, but, like, this is how you get out...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Pathfinder?
Yeah.
You're playing...
Lifeline.
Plastic.
What are you playing?
Wait, can we do prison?
UPDATED!
In Canada what?
You gotta say something.
Okay, as I was saying, like, to get out of jury duty, if it's, like, something that's, like, a really high prolific case, you can be like, I sympathize with the murderer.
And then you're... you already have, like, a bias towards the...
And then they're like, oh, I guess we can't have you.
Yeah, because you have... to be in jury duty, you have to have no biases at all.
So you can... you can just be like, I don't know, I think he could be... I think he was a nice guy before...
I think he's a nice guy.
So you get out of jury duty.
I'm not doing jury duty.
Why don't you just say that to the victims instead?
Like, I sympathize with them.
Well, you don't say it to the victims, you say it to the judge, because they're picking the people who are doing jury duty.
You know, you're not a bad...
Yeah, so they won't know you said that, you know?
The victims won't know.
True.
You're spitting.
Only the judge will know.
And then they'll be like, we can't put you in jury duty because you already have a bias towards the murderer.
I don't think you have to worry at all, Doki.
I don't think you're ever getting picked based off these statements you said.
Never.
They're watching.
They're watching you now.
Take this seriously and show us LG wig?
What do you mean take this seriously?
That is a joke, guys.
This is a joke.
It's not a joke.
Get her.
It's a joke.
It was a joke, guys.
For legal reasons, this is a joke.
No, for legal reasons, she's being serious.
Get her.
Do not take my advice.
Minus tempo on caustic.
Wait, we don't have to peek in again.
I'm gonna fucking cry.
Again?
I might cry.
Just jump right now before someone just jumps.
Tempo jump, please.
Before somebody tries to take the- Why am I jumping?
Before somebody takes Turbine from us.
Yeah, please.
We need something in this world.
Yeah.
How do we not have a fucking peek in again?
This game actually wants me to go laugh about this question.
Guys, I don't wanna be bottom five, guys.
What did you just say?
I don't wanna be bottom five, guys.
No, that's gonna sell.
No, that shit is gone.
What are you talking about?
We are bottom five.
Bottom five for sure.
No.
What happened?
We used to be so good at this game.
What happened to- We were supposed to do challenger circuits.
You are still doing it.
Yes, but if- I don't know.
I don't have high hopes anymore.
I never had high hopes to begin with.
I can't believe you said that actually.
I'm like lowkey impressed that you said that.
Hey, tempo.
Please.
Just do that.
Boing.
I got- I pinged it too.
Oh my god.
Wait, I have the perfect excuse.
I'm categorized as platform.
You guys should have been carrying me.
Of course, yeah.
I know.
You guys should have been carrying me.
This is so embarrassing.
Hey guys, I'm ready.
Hey, tempo.
Based on the zone- I mean, not that- I mean, no offense.
Where do you think this is going?
I mean, he should know because he watches so many scrims.
Yeah, Wig.
You should know because you watch so many scrims.
Okay, both of you guys should know.
Both of us should know.
Both of us should fucking shit.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah, why just me?
I'm asleep.
That's true actually.
That's true, yeah.
I mean, I wanna go into energy depot but there's a team there.
We should just keep walking up towards this.
Okay, I'm following wing.
You make the yellow dots and I just follow.
Okay.
Yeah.
Let's start a moving.
I have no idea where the zones are going.
God.
Now I know why no one picked a turbine.
This loot sucks.
Honestly, my loot's pretty good.
We got scammed by a cerca beacon.
Hammond, that's fine.
That's fine.
Oh, they're far, they're far.
Yeah, far, far.
We're good.
That was pretty dog shit.
I have no attachments on anything.
Or bats.
I'm gonna get a bat right now though.
I'm not great, I'll be honest.
So you lied?
I'm not BAT.
You literally said your...
Did I say I was good?
You said your loot was pretty good.
Let's go this way.
We gotta move out.
Oh my god, I fucking need that.
Fuck me.
Just pick it up, pick it up.
Oh, oh, oh.
Just go up there.
Tempo, you go up there first.
And just watch out.
Wait, they're fighting behind us.
Come back here, come back here.
Get in front of me.
Kill him.
Where?
Okay, okay, I'm turning around.
We got a point.
It's time to leave.
We're not last.
Wait, they scanned us.
We shouldn't be there.
Go back down, go back down.
They scanned us.
They can't see us.
Wait, wait, wait.
We gotta wait for my zip line.
We're gonna go across the small building over here.
Come here, come here, come here.
Take this.
We're not gonna die.
Okay, I didn't hesitate.
I didn't hesitate this time.
Good.
Nice.
Revalid.
See, we're good.
We're gonna play here.
We're gonna play here for right now.
Don't stand on the roof!
Tempo, tempo.
No roof action.
Okay.
There's a 4x...
Oh wait, I need that actually.
He's a 2x4 for me.
Oh wait, this is nice.
I'm dropping a 2x.
Okay, I don't need it.
We're good.
There's a lot of people rotating in over here.
I'm just don't know where this is going.
42 damage and a kill.
Guys, we're not last.
We're 19th.
And we got a point.
That's like one point right now.
Tempo, this is gonna be for you.
Okay, Tempo.
We need you to get us blue armor.
Why is no one getting this care package?
Did you scan the care package already?
I did, yeah.
They got it.
It's fine.
Here's where it is.
We're doing it.
I'm so proud of all of us.
Oh my god.
You don't need a heal Tempo.
I will give you one little...
one little heal.
Great talk.
We're not wasting meds.
Alright, we're good.
We're good.
We'll make a play.
I got the They're over here.
There's a lot of people rotating towards us.
That's why I'm confusing where the zone is going.
I'm scared.
What if they come to us from behind?
No, we're fine.
Tempo, do you want to put some traps out here buddy?
Yeah, so we know they walk up on us.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh my god, we're so smart.
You're getting it.
We're getting there.
We're figuring this out.
I don't see anybody yet.
I hope they kill more people.
So we can be 18th place.
It should be on the real list.
It sounds so much better than 20th.
It's insane.
Yeah, I know.
For some reason, 18th place sounds a lot better than being 26th.
18th place sounds fantastic.
I'll take 18th place all day.
I know.
I'm not using this two times if no one wants it.
I have a 2x4.
I don't need it.
Okay.
I should be coming from this side, right?
I'm not picking anything.
I'm so sorry.
I don't know where to go.
We have redeploy.
We don't.
We have...
I have a Moby.
We don't have redeploy.
I do have a zipline.
So efficiency.
Did you make this work?
18th place!
Let's go!
Green War for another team.
If it goes towards garden, I rotate the river.
There is still a guy here.
There is?
Oh, I see him.
Probably out below.
Green Pathfinder.
That might be out.
To be honest.
Okay.
Someone type in this chat right now to not push us.
I'm so real for that.
Max, stay still.
Can we get some collision going?
Can we get some collision going so I never...
I mean, let me...
There's no rules in Twitch Rivals about colluding.
They never said no colluding.
They did not say it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's see how bad my zone call was, yeah?
Let's see.
We got scanned.
What were you even looking for?
We got surveyed over here.
I don't know.
Feel free to roast, though.
Let's see how it goes.
Guys, for legal reasons, that's a joke, guys.
Do not go to this chat.
Do not actually go to this chat.
Because I think he'll actually push us now that he knows we're there.
So do not go to this chat.
All right.
We got to go Rift.
Come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come.
Okay.
And then just a whole team just flew in.
We're so chonked.
Oh, no.
A whole team just flew in this building.
And this building crashed.
Take the zip and go there.
I want to go next if we can.
You say we can get out.
I'm going to put a zip line down.
Come here, come here.
All right.
Oh, there's a team here.
Fuck me.
Go back, go back, go back.
We can't go this way.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Go back, go back, go back.
We literally can't go this way.
Dude, this is...
How do we not have a...
I have a...
I'm going to drop down my lifeline package.
How do we not have a lifeline package?
Maybe we'll get something here.
Okay.
You guys stay here.
Yeah, yeah.
You guys are going to get loot.
Get EvoCache yourselves.
Yeah.
I'm going to go check up on Energy Depot until we get rotated.
Just stay down here.
One second.
Are we going to get on that or no?
Nope.
There was nothing.
There was a purple heavy mag.
Yeah.
Wait, there's people behind us.
Wait, where are you?
Where are you?
Behind us.
You're watching guys.
Yeah, yeah.
Come with me.
Tembo, keep running.
Keep running.
I'm looking over you, buddy.
No.
Why me?
Why is it me?
I'm dead too.
Fuck.
It's time to go.
Run, run, run.
You can craft us.
This is exactly why I went lifeline.
This is exactly why.
How does that happen?
How do we get walked up on?
I'm getting shagged on?
I'm dead.
Bro, this is...
What the fuck is this, man?
Bro, when are we going to get a fucking evac?
We haven't got one evac and we haven't got a fucking beacon.
Hey, wait, wait.
We got to kill them.
So it's not a zero.
We got one point.
No, one kill.
Bro, what?
Bro, not a single evac.
Not a single beacon.
I'm going to lose it.
I literally did not hear anything for the team that walked up on us, to be fair.
To be fair.
Because that's not even the team that killed you guys that just killed me.
It's a completely different squad.
Wait, your squad is already on red.
With 34 damage.
Bro, that was Max's team too.
I'm so sad.
How do I...
How do we not get a beacon?
How do we not get a single scan in three games out of Command Center?
Or fucking Turbine?
All I'm saying is, like, I think we need to let Tempo roam free and maybe we'll kill...
Yeah.
Tempo, I might just make you...
Is that what we're doing?
I might make you play a controller legend and you just literally land on a beacon somewhere.
And if you make it to us, by the time we get his dome, we're good.
We're so good.
I swear, this is like the best strat.
We let him roam free.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You literally land on one of those where you scan it across the map and you just meet up with him.
Wait, what map is next then?
Next is gonna be Geyser again.
Geyser...
That's what I'm saying, bro.
Geyser, we should have a beacon somewhere, man.
Oh no, not even Commanders League, a 90% and fucking...
I'm losing it.
Bro, I just wanna get into one fight, like an actual fight.
I know.
I wanna beat you to the end game.
This is crazy.
This is insane.
Guys, okay.
I'm gonna go back to the game.
Okay, okay.
Okay, Temple.
I believe in you to be free.
Be free, Temple.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe we got walked up on and Temple, I didn't even hear anything.
We didn't hear the walk up at all.
I have no idea how this possible, dude.
Release him from his shackles.
Why is that two walking up on me?
It was Max's team.
I fucking knew he was gonna kill us.
Different fucking teams.
Two teams that pursued our building.
Oh my god, that is insane.
Now I understand Sweet Dreams Restoration not getting beacons.
It's insane.
It's nice that you're doing a Watch Party in your own tournament.
I'm banning you.
Oh my god, three.
This is like your own tournament too.
Why is your own tournament so fucked up?
Why is it so cursed against you?
Why do they hate us bro?
Why do they hate us?
Okay, we're back.
What do you mean we're back?
We were already back.
It can't be my own tournament and then we have a good time.
But those of you that know, we're gonna have a good time.
It's okay.
Those teams that are winning right now, they're not having as fun as we are.
Do you think that's actually true though?
They might be winning.
Do you think that's true?
Do you believe that with your whole chest?
They might be winning, but they're not having as fun as we are.
That couldn't be more true.
I agree.
Because somehow, I'm rage induced, but I'm just having a great time.
Just remember that winning isn't everything.
They might win more money and be more financially secured.
But...
But what did we do?
We laughed more.
But homies for life.
I know.
Actually homies for life.
Aren't they dead?
Oh, they go to the corner.
Yeah.
Those teams that are doing much better than us and that are winning, you know they won't be back together after this tournament.
Also, like, they're fucking nerds a little bit, right?
Yeah, they won't.
They're kind of a little bit nerds.
Yeah, they're fucking nerds.
How dare they be good at a video game?
I'm just saying.
I have the courage to be good.
But you know they won't reconvene back together and do a reunion or anything.
They're gonna forget each other the next day.
Yeah.
But we won't.
We're relatable.
Chat, how did that... is this making you feel better, chat?
Yeah, we're like...
Honestly, because we're here.
We're like the team where it's like if we can be in a tournament, so can you.
Anything is possible for you guys.
If they are allowing us to play this tournament with all these pro players who are infinitely better than us, that means you can too one day.
Oh, speak for yourself.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
I'm included in that?
I'm really better than you.
I won't say though.
After those shots I just gave them, that was... they're definitely infinitely better.
I just gave them 14 warning shots.
See, you're so relatable.
I'm right.
Thank you.
You're so relatable.
No, I'm just down to earth.
You know what I mean?
Like, get it?
Yeah, exactly.
You're humans.
Like when chat watches other pro players, they're like, oh my god, these shots are inhumane.
That's what I'm saying.
There's no way he's able to... but then when they watch you, they're like, oh yeah, he's definitely a real person.
That can be fun.
He's definitely a player.
Yeah.
From Apex Legends.
I shit just like you guys.
Yeah, yeah.
And they're like... people will be like, oh my god, he's on controller and still missing?
So relatable.
Guys,
I have a secret plan.
What's your secret plan?
What's your...
There's two teams contesting at Harvester.
So?
I wouldn't let me brush.
Yeah, what does that mean for us?
We're literally on Geyser.
I'm not third.
I'm on Geyser.
I'm on Bando.
I'm someone you see.
You know exactly what...
Internet crash.
You know exactly what that means.
What the fuck does that mean?
Yo, we need some KP.
There's no way we're gonna be able to get there from Geyser without getting shot at.
Who said we're landing Geyser?
Okay, is Temple gonna...
Temple, you can third party them for us.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Throw, throw, throw.
Great idea, bro.
I'm gonna go to Geyser.
Okay, you two land Geyser and loot.
I'll land Harvester and try to sneak like a free kill or two.
Yeah.
And then I'll run away.
Yeah, exactly.
And then if you...
And then I'll loot No Name and then I'll meet up with you guys at Geyser.
No, no, if he fails, if he fails, we have...
We can just craft the at Geyser.
Yeah, we can craft him in Geyser.
That is so smart.
Did you guys just watch that Vantage?
That looked like us out there.
That was crazy.
I was thinking it was Strat.
You have to do a full fucking...
No, I had...
I had...
I had max POV there.
Oh, okay.
Okay, okay, yeah.
Well, we'll...
I mean, we are sending Tempo out to roam.
So, Tempo, you're gonna land on Harvester.
Oh, my game crashed.
Oh.
Wait, it didn't crash.
My Discord restart set itself, but I'm okay now.
Yeah.
We have a plan.
We have guaranteed one kill plan.
We're just gonna...
We're just gonna let Tempo roam free around the map.
For...
I'm gonna go third Harvester and then Suicide and then...
And then you guys craft me a geyser and then bring me back to life.
Yeah.
That's the best plan you've ever had.
Should guarantee us one kill.
Yeah.
One point is very zero.
And then we're back in the game.
I don't know about back in the game, but yeah.
Back in the game.
Yeah.
See, now I'm kinda happy we didn't play this zone again.
You know what I mean?
I think you're just coping, Wig.
No, never.
I think you're just coping.
No, this makes sense.
Playing this zone has been way too difficult.
I think you're just coping, Wig.
I'm not kidding.
I actually went 0 for 7 on Sentinel shots to cover for you guys.
I said I'm covering for you guys and I did not cover once.
I'm covering.
We ran up.
We died.
That's why we're so relatable.
Thank you.
People watch us for the relatability.
No, I know.
I'm down to earth.
I get it.
Thank you.
Yeah.
People are like...
People don't wanna watch a robot.
They wanna watch somebody that can make mistakes despite how many they make.
They wanna just feel like they...
Is it a mistake?
Yeah.
They make mistakes.
Despite how many they make.
Look, I'm saying as a team.
As a team.
I'm not singling out...
That's better.
Way better.
As a team, guys.
I'm not singling out anybody here.
But if anyone wants to give out examples of how they made mistakes, that's on them.
For sure.
I can't think of a mistake for my end, but like...
Oh, no.
Never.
No, no.
No, we never...
No.
That's because you don't make them.
But like if anybody...
If anybody else wants to tell what mistakes they made, that's totally fine.
Yeah, Tempo, if you wanna open up, bro, we're not gonna judge.
Yeah, yeah.
You wanna open up too, Tempo.
Like...
Zero mistakes.
Oh!
Oh, zero mistakes.
Oh, okay.
Then we know.
Zero is a little delusional.
No, no.
Just a little.
I like how when I was like, I don't remember my mistakes.
You're like, yeah, you're right.
And then for Tempo, it's like, oh, you're delusional.
I don't remember what happened.
I don't know.
Okay, my mistake is just...
Why can't you put that down?
It went out the window.
Double Moby is crazy and we can't even find an evac fucking tower.
We can't even find... there was no fucking anything in my package.
I got purple evac.
That was great.
And they got double Moby.
And we can't find a fucking evac.
Unreal.
It's okay.
Oh, there you go.
All our luck...
I think it's because you're the tournament organizer.
Every fucking luck is not with us.
That's lowkey true though.
I feel like I actually cursed myself by being the organizer.
You should have been a caster.
What?
You should have...
Okay, you know what would have been funny?
Honestly, Greek should have been a caster in your tournament.
Honestly, they asked me if I wanted to play or cast.
I don't think I regret my decision yet.
I feel like it would have been so funny that Greek would...
If Greek was a caster in your own tournament.
In my own, that would be so funny.
That would be so fucked.
Just make him watch?
Yeah, just make him do a watch party.
That would be so fucked.
Wait, whose team is this?
Oh my god.
You still casted it so far.
Wait a minute.
Ew.
Can't what?
It was a two.
It's anonymous mode.
They are, for some reason.
They did touch us.
Yeah, it's been on this entire game.
How the hell do you feel?
I didn't notice.
Just self revive on Lifeline.
It's crazy, ggs.
That boy, Yania would win.
I'm kinda happy about that to be honest.
Yeah, you know what, them winning is like we're winning, yeah Temple you got our.
No, we're not landing.
No, let him land on Harvester.
You can just craft me.
We can craft him.
Something is alluded to, it's the smartest thing we can ever do.
That's like Gary and I being weied.
Guarantee one point.
Make sure you know they're going there though.
I just need a fuse.
No, he analyzed the situation.
Yeah.
Yeah, he made a spreadsheet and everything.
How many games is this?
Is this like six games or five games?
Three more.
We got three more to get.
Okay, this plan should work.
Three more to get.
Oh boy.
25 points?
So we need eight a game?
Wait, Jent is going...
Harvester.
Wait, he's going Harvester.
I think that's one of the teams.
Someone else is going Harvester.
We haven't...
Janja and...
Janja and who?
Where's Jent?
We're two Harvesters here.
Who's the two Harvester team?
Oh yeah, Janja and Jent.
Oh shit, I'm gonna be like, we're landing Harvester too.
No, no, no.
Give him no warning.
Let Santan by himself, bro.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, we need to wait for the Legends.
I need to be able to throw like a million nades at them.
And just run away.
No, you're supposed to get one kill.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
A million nades, one or two kills, and then run away.
A million nades.
You're so confident in game now.
Bro, you need to die.
No, I'm gonna...
If you die by the time we're leaving Geyser, then we can't craft you.
I gotta loot No Name.
I'll kill them, and then...
Oh wait.
I'll kill all of them and then just loot all of Harvester myself.
Exactly!
You go in there and just guarantee a kill.
It doesn't matter.
Just guarantee a kill for us.
I'm catching...
Fusey.
What are they saying in the chat, bro?
There's no Fuse.
Pathfinder, Octane, Bloodhound, Rampart, Catalyst.
Alright, so obviously I'm playing...
I guess I'll play either Globa or Newcastle.
Which one should I do?
I feel like we're always poor on loot.
I feel like...
Yeah, yeah, definitely.
I feel like we have been doing really well in the loot department.
Just saying.
Yeah, I mean, what dickhead put us on this PLA?
Oh wait.
This is the one game that doesn't have an assault.
No.
That's fine.
It's fine.
You don't need it.
All you need to do is just kill them.
That's really it.
If you're dropping over there, we need the ring.
We're gonna have to wait for you to craft the ring.
I'll just kill all of them and then do the ring at Harvester.
You're so optimistic.
I hate it.
Okay.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm down.
This is what our brain is telling us.
We need a rubber to listen to our brain.
Yeah.
Rampart or Catalyst then?
Well, that's on you guys.
I'm good with my choices.
Who are you going for?
Left and then...
Who are you playing, Doki?
I'm playing Loba for the loot.
Because we're always poor.
Yeah.
I'm gonna play Octane.
We're always broke.
What do you mean?
We're so broke all the time.
This is it.
This time.
No.
I actually think this is the one.
I'm not kidding.
This is the one.
100%.
Wait.
Since you're the headliner, right?
Can you make them make up an award for us?
Like the most...
the happiest team?
Or something?
The happiest team?
I feel like it would be first.
Gotta be a little bit happier.
Okay.
I'm not saying my happiness levels are down.
But you know what I mean?
The most fun team.
Like...
That one we take.
Teams with the best vibes.
Yeah.
Tell them.
Tell the...
Twitch Rivals staff to pick...
You know the Golden Cockies?
Yeah!
They should nominate us.
The Golden Cockies?
What is that?
What is it called?
The Golden Pants?
The Pants!
What is it called?
Cackies?
Cackies!
Yes!
Is that how you pronounce it?
The Golden Cockies.
They have to nominate us for the Golden Cockies.
And then we win by sheer popular vote.
Unless Hal is in there.
So obviously we're not gonna win.
No, no, no.
Your VTuber army wins.
No, no.
I think...
I don't know about that.
We'll pee fast.
Is that time?
Yeah, there's time.
Okay, I'm going.
I'm going.
Okay.
Who is everyone running... oh.
It's okay.
They're not gonna start the game.
You're not gonna start the game.
We're so fine.
Yep.
Oh my gosh.
Alright, alright.
So the plan, Tempo.
You, Harvester.
You die.
I wish I had a fuse.
For a kill.
Wait, what are you playing in?
Cat.
But if I get a kill and I can run, I'm gonna run through No Name and then meet up with you guys to wherever you run.
Cause no one's looting No Name.
Okay, but like...
Wait, wait.
How do I land in Harvester to grief?
Yeah, I was gonna say how are you gonna... how are you gonna...
get to us?
Y'all can just punch some...
Oh, no wait.
No, I can't.
You're gonna punch...
Don't punch someone.
I was gonna say punch them into the lava and then block them with Rampart... punch them into the lava and then block them with Rampart walls.
Bro, just...
Don't... don't...
Tempo, your only job.
Do what you can to get a kill.
Do not trip.
That is your only mission.
That's really it.
I believe you, Tempo.
I believe in us.
I can't believe our first team was our peak.
I can get... I can get two kills.
I have good news.
Wait, what's the good news?
Greek isn't last with us.
Wait, we're last too?
No, that's good.
That's good.
Wait, the score...
Wait, Greek?
Who's Greek on...
Wait, we have five points.
Yes!
So he's guaranteed last.
Oh my god, it's the best M.O.I.
Oh my god, it's amazing.
Wait, who's Greek with?
Reptar.
Reptar and...
Didn't Reptar pick first?
Yeah.
Oh, Doki just exploded.
Wait, what about Lich?
He's sending tunnel that's close to the balloon.
What's tunnel that's close to the balloon?
Wait...
In Harvester.
He picked first though.
How did he...
It's the curse.
I can feel the curse.
There's a tunnel?
Oh, it started.
You guys have your picks?
I have my pick.
Wig?
I bet you Wig ran into Greek.
I have minus five.
We only have five points.
You have your pick?
Who am I playing?
I thought you were playing Octane.
Yeah, I'm playing Loba.
Yeah, I got cat.
I was gonna say, we only have five points.
We can't have a minus five.
I mean, even if we got ten points here, we're still bottom five.
Wait, what?
Where are you seeing the scores?
The Google Sheet thing isn't updated.
I'm just guessing.
I'm guessing here.
Oh, okay.
Bro, what happened to us?
We fell off, man.
We were never on.
What do you mean?
We did so well.
We did so well last Rivals.
What happened to us?
Watch this redemption round.
Temple's gonna kill it right here.
Okay, Temple, just remember.
Just leave us.
Remember to solo.
You didn't pick.
I picked Pathfinder, not Octane.
It's fine.
Is Pathfinder fine?
Oh, it is.
Okay.
No minus five.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, my God.
There's the zero points.
Holy fuck, dude.
Oh, my God.
Goodbye, Temple.
Goodbye.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
Pathfinder's a choice, chat.
We're good.
Yo, they see one random person just flying.
Yo, there is a contest here.
Yes, there is.
I see the contest.
Oh, my God.
They're landing on each other.
Okay, don't get off me.
I'm gonna go left here.
Okay, okay.
They're literally landing on each other.
Temple, I am waiting for that.
I am...
I am waiting... There's no fucking stance on us anyway, so we're fine.
I'm dead.
Wait, what?
No, I'm okay.
I'm alive.
Oh, my God.
There's someone landing inside the no-name.
Okay, okay.
You scared the shit out of me there.
That scared the shit out of me too.
Yeah.
Wait, they're not...
They're not fighting?
How about you need to die?
Wait, you guys have beacon over there?
No, of course not.
No, we need you to die, brother.
We need you to die.
We were solely dependent on you dying here.
Yo, I got his beacon.
I'm running back to you.
I got a beacon?
I'm stealing their loot and I'm running with their beacon.
I thought they were contesting.
What happened?
They are.
They're contesting very far away.
Oh, okay.
Very far away.
It's okay.
I got a beacon.
We got a beacon.
We have a god spot here, guys.
We're zoned?
Yeah, we have a zone on us.
I'm running.
Look at the zone.
It's gonna pull up towards the overlook side.
We got a scan?
Now they're gonna think we're a duo.
Oh, no.
They're gonna send us.
Oh, my god.
I will bet my entire life they send us.
Our whole plan was for Tempo to die, but yet he's still alive.
I'm still fucking alive, man.
I left this house for you, except for the helmet.
It's fine.
I'm more focused on these guys actually coming to kill us.
In the end, I'm not even trying to be funny.
I absolutely am.
What if Tempo is the one that crafts us in the end?
That would be actually so...
That would actually be poetic.
That would be beautiful.
That would be so sad.
No, I have a W.
Oh, I have a Havoc Turbo.
Now we won.
I have a R9 Bolt.
I'm only short range.
I'm gonna craft a...
Alright, Tempo, are you okay?
I'm gonna craft a bat if you...
Yeah, I'm going to you.
I'm going to you.
Okay, I'm gonna craft a bat then.
I'm making sure I'm not getting sent down.
We're okay right now.
We're good.
Yeah, we're okay.
We need to get to the zone now, Tempo.
So get over here quick and we're gonna go.
Yeah, I'm here now.
We're gonna get inside Overlook somewhere.
I just don't know where the zone is exactly ending.
That's my evac.
Woo!
Nice.
I have an increased range for my ult.
I can ult whenever, but I'll wait a little bit.
I'm evacing to you.
Wait, he's gonna evac to us?
That's fine.
I was always gonna go here.
That's okay, whatever.
Wait, are we staying here?
No, we're going.
We're going.
Okay, I'm coming over here.
I'm towards Overlook for sure.
That's where it's gonna end.
Any of that fucking shit up top, any of those houses up top, bro, we are vibing.
Like, we're actually chilling.
We can get routed on here pretty hard.
So, we gotta watch out.
We have no scans.
And team's gonna have Bloodhound.
So let me go first and whatever happens, just run away and craft me.
I'm giving you the lead here.
I'm not kidding.
At any moment, if you think we're losing this gunfight, you guys run.
I don't care if I have two.
What if that's every moment?
Who looted inside here?
I did.
I have an extra battle to start.
You guys are far.
Okay, I was gonna say, I can loot the vault right now.
Oh, loot the vault!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna loot the vault.
I'm watching this thingy.
I need to close my blinds, cause I actually can't see.
Yeah, I was gonna say, where the fuck did you go?
We're good.
Let's see.
I'm gonna grab...
I'm gonna grab the knockback shield.
Yeah.
Knockback shield.
Never heard of that.
Let's do it.
Knockdown.
I got the knockdown shield, guys.
If you guys get down, I have gold.
If you get knocked, just get back up.
Yeah, it's a knockback.
Yup, yup, yup.
Alright, keep on moving.
Keep on moving.
We're good.
I'm right behind you.
We're doing great, guys.
Seriously.
Not last.
Nineteen plays.
Each placement is an improvement.
Wait, wait.
Don't come over here.
Okay, okay.
Come, come, come.
We're good.
Okay.
I'm putting all my trust in you.
I shouldn't, but like...
Don't do that, please.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna give you more pressure.
Alright, keep moving.
I'll give you comms real quick.
One sec.
Can't tell if there's someone here or not.
I cannot, dude.
I don't think so.
I'm gonna go on height.
Okay.
I got scanned.
Yeah, we're good.
I can hit beacon here, too.
We're gonna play back here and hit the beacon late, okay?
Okay.
How about right here?
Tempo, you have anything you should this guy with?
Yeah.
Can we climb up there?
No, we can't.
We can like be on the ledge here.
I think I can give you guys a zipline though if you need it.
Yeah, we need a zipline here.
You guys can get over here to zipline.
I wanna put it down below.
Alright, yeah, yeah.
We're here.
Yeah, come over.
I'll have 20% on it.
Just stay up here for now.
Just put out... Did you put Kaku's over here, Tempo, at all?
Uh, yeah.
I threw one up over there.
Yeah, we're gonna do that for right now.
This is ramparts.
So teams are definitely gonna get down here for sure.
Alright.
I have only short range.
Okay.
I have long range.
I'm good.
I have flat.
I ping the longbow and stuff.
Yeah.
Good.
I already have one.
I'm showing.
Yeah, yeah, but for tempo I meant.
Let me check if there's any sniper... Oh, there's sniper ammo here if you need it.
Oh, I might take it afterwards, yeah.
I'm just gonna put it on this side to make sure no one pushes us.
Are you fucking...
poking them with a fucking...
Okay.
One sec.
I'll do this for you guys.
You guys stay there, okay?
I'm gonna do this for y'all just in case you wanna come up here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I wanna be free.
I'll play the other side though.
You can go from there.
I'll be here.
They're fighting over here.
They're fighting.
Like how hard?
How hard?
Hard fighting.
They just inted each other.
They kill each other?
Like, okay.
Yeah, they're inting each other.
Yeah.
I don't think there was a way for us to get there.
I'm gonna put a low ball right here so...
See if there's a sniper.
Go for it.
I'm gonna hit the beacon when it's closest.
I have my zone thing now.
So we're good to go.
Pew!
Oh, there's snipers for you.
There's snipers.
154.
Okay.
And there's sniper...
scopes.
There's sniper scopes.
Dubs.
I hit the... I did my upgrade.
I'm gonna purge.
Someone get the stuff before it's gone.
I'm going now.
Before someone shoots it.
Look at the zone.
We need to move up.
Okay.
We need to take more space in zone.
We have a good... We need to get this house right here, okay?
Alright.
I'm heading over to you.
Yeah, you're good.
We get in here, we're vibing.
Make sure we... Okay.
Now when we're in this house, we 100% can get sent on.
Just play slow.
My Q takes someone behind us.
Yeah, there's two behind me.
There's two behind me.
Can you cover me?
Yeah, you're good.
I'm looking for you.
I'm looking for you, vibing.
Okay.
That's right.
I don't wanna dive through the window.
I'm here.
You're good.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
We're vibing.
We're good.
I'm vibing.
I could've Q'd, but I didn't because I had more confidence in you guys as a team.
Oh, that was... Thank you.
I think...
We're good.
I had a lot of confidence in all of you to protect me.
So I never Q'd.
I would definitely Q.
Me and Teb were not good.
That means I trust my homies.
Get your homies.
Thank you so much.
My life is in your hands.
That's too much.
No pressure.
I don't even know where I got shot at.
I think we can farm you guys.
Oh, right here.
On Crafter.
Okay.
But the zone's actually not bad for us.
We're fine right now.
We're doing pretty good.
Anyone in Big House over here at Tempo?
Do you know?
I'mma check.
You guys stay there.
Woah, now I see it.
Now I know what you guys are talking about.
No one's in here.
I mean, they might be routing it, but I think they sent it.
I'm gonna go in here.
One sec.
Just wait.
Okay.
We can't craft you if you die.
I know.
You're good.
There's no one in here.
Come to me.
Okay.
I'm gonna need that Tempo.
Yeah, I'm gonna need you.
Need what?
You're spamming me?
Woo!
Am I...
Oh!
I lived!
How does she do this?
You're good.
Take your time.
I'm good.
I'm okay.
How does she fucking do it?
I'm losing so many cells.
It's crazy.
I'm just gonna not peek anymore.
I'm good.
We're good.
We're all good.
I don't know how the fuck we did it in here, but we did it, guys.
I don't know how I lived that, but let's go.
I'm very proud of you.
Good shit, guys.
Okay.
Are you sent on?
Are you team honest now?
Underneath our house.
Underneath us, which is fine.
Okay.
I put a Loba stick on the door.
They're shooting my stick, but that's okay.
I grabbed some stuff before they could.
If you guys want more ammo, there's some here.
I'm gonna screen.
Ow.
Tempo, we don't have enough meds.
Don't peek too much.
You guys can grab ammo here.
Oh, there's 39 cells.
Oh my god.
I'm chilling out.
Oh, I should've picked cells.
I'm so stupid.
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
Oh yeah, that's right.
Tempo, you wanna pick?
You wanna...
do the thing?
Yeah, one sec.
39...
33 cells is gigantic for us, guys.
Yeah, that's so nice.
Good fucking call on the Loba, dude.
Top 14!
Top 14, guys!
I told you!
I know because we're always poor!
Every game!
We have to play Loba to have anything in life.
Wig.
What's up?
Ooh, I'll take that if you don't need it.
I grabbed the charge rifle.
I'll put the next one here.
You need a sniper ammo, buddy?
I can give you something you need.
I picked it all up from the thing.
Alright, big dog.
Let me not have any more.
It's loot time.
Loot time.
My existence is to just sit here because I don't have any range.
Yeah, you're good.
Just the team underneath us.
Make sure we don't get one.
I'll aim at this window.
Wait.
They're on our roof now.
Oh, they're on our roof.
I feel like they might rampart our door.
Honestly, them being on our roof is pretty good for us.
Yeah, they're like our wall.
How is this guy walking up if there's a team on our roof?
They're breaching.
As I say, they're not gonna push us and this team just literally sits there for free.
It's crazy.
They have their priorities.
Oh yeah, we're locked in.
We're so good, guys.
We got good spots.
Look at us.
We're fucking killing it.
We just need a team to die around us.
That's what I'm saying.
We're gonna get so much loot.
We should be good for next zone.
I'm pretty sure the next zone is gonna pull towards us.
Yeah, me too.
I think.
I could be wrong.
I'm just gonna believe in you.
Thank you.
That's actually the nicest thing you're saying.
I've always believed in you.
Thank you so much.
Like why is YB and CC with you for seven... maybe hypothetically seven hours?
Why is this guy just out in the open?
Three and a half hours.
He's just out in the open shooting.
I don't know how he's doing that with a team on our roof.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I'm confused.
They're not looking at him.
That's how.
They might push for the knockers to be honest.
100%, yeah.
I'm a little horny.
How is this team on the roof not shooting these guys?
And what's this?
The third on our roof?
I'm gonna grab this armor.
And then also these shields.
Oh my god bro.
The cells are such a vibe.
Such a vibe saver.
It's crazy.
Good shit.
Let us go.
They can't kill us because we always have unlimited cells.
This has to be his teammate that's on our roof.
There's no way these guys are able to peek this.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
I mean this guy is just in the open.
This is crazy.
Yeah.
If anyone wants...
Who the hell would run Newcastle in this lobby?
Someone that's not Geyser for POI.
And someone that's very confident in their ability.
Yeah.
Oh, they took this.
One team on RV.
Oh, nice.
Oh my god, he's flesh.
That team should die.
There's no way someone's gonna let them do that.
Well, I think they're doing it right now.
They are doing it.
They're good.
They're chilling.
Guys, guys, guys, they're coming soon.
Holy shit.
Listen, we gotta hold it down here, guys.
We've been top 10 before.
Don't jinx it.
Genuinely, if we get sent on and people are trying to push in our building, we do not contest.
We back up here and throw grenades here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm being so serious.
I'm so for real right now.
I'm not even trying to be funny.
I opened their door.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, they might be out.
Does Sheila break through cat door or no?
Yes, yes, yes.
Really?
Yeah, that's why I was like be careful of this door.
I heard the wind up and I'm scared now.
I heard the wind up.
The wind up is giving me fear.
Alright, also just keep instant dropping your low ball to wherever you get it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
20%, 20%.
Where's this care pack at?
Can I scan this again?
We don't need beacons.
We don't need all those fucking ring scans.
Oh, you end up getting a...
Tempo actually ended up getting a charge rifle.
It was in this room.
We're good.
We just got to make sure... Tempo, if you just get sent on, just like literally just walk back in.
I have another low ball.
Oh, nice, nice.
That's great.
More people are going to die near us too.
This is fantastic.
I might actually just take grenades.
There's a lot for...
I took two grenades.
We need them.
Me too.
We're definitely not going to need anything else.
We should be fine.
You guys are just picking up the grenades that you threw down.
Why did you pick up the grenades we dropped?
I'm sick to my stomach, dude.
Fuck me, man.
That's pretty funny.
On us, on us.
Watch out.
It's a Sheila.
Take the door.
Okay.
I'm going to...
I'm going to collapse this.
I'm going to look for picks here on the backside.
Just make sure we don't get hit.
I'm looking with you, just in case.
We're good.
We're vibing.
Top 12, guys.
Zone, are we in?
Alright, guys.
Don't...
We're in.
We're in this corner.
We're playing that corner.
We walk out late.
We're going to show no presence once the zone closes.
The only way they know we're here is from our low ball.
That's fine.
I need to get fucking purple, bro, for a zipline really bad.
We got to get purple here.
There's a guy.
There's a Newcastle behind this wall.
Alright, we got scanned from behind.
There's a Newcastle right here behind this.
Fuck me, bro.
I need to get purple.
Oh, he's rotating to the left.
Oh, I couldn't see him in time.
It's a little rat.
He's a little rat guy.
It's a little rat guy?
Yeah, he's a little rat.
He's ratting up there.
I have low ball in 20.
We're good.
We're doing great.
We're doing great, guys.
I need my zipline here so we take less damage on zip.
Fuck me, I missed the shot.
Oh my god, let's fucking go.
Holy shit.
Alright.
Oh my god, I want to shoot this guy so bad.
I have low ball in 10.
Yeah, we're good.
We're good.
Just keep holding.
Literally make sure that no one pushes this door.
That's all we need right now.
Just make sure we don't get shielded in the back late.
Yeah, I'm looking for you guys.
We're good.
I'm going to keep staring here too.
One sec.
I'm looking at this door just in case.
Yeah, you guys look forward.
I have ult here.
I'm going to put my ult right here.
I regret the decision fully.
That guy's a beast.
That zipline is so fast.
Alright, I'm going to back here.
There's a red for us here if you need it.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, refresh it.
You should refresh it.
It's a refresh, not an actual red.
Yeah.
I'm going to take batteries.
I am going to grab...
Wait, do I need batteries?
No.
I'm going to grab AA.
We're good.
We just played that corner, guys.
We're just going to play that corner.
I'm going to grab an aid then.
How in are we?
Fighting in that room.
Kind of.
Tempo, you got to stay in this corner.
We're good.
We're going to zip out late game somewhere.
We have a lot of room actually.
Wait, are we going to die in here?
No, no, no.
We're good.
We're going to walk out late.
Okay, okay.
Only one of us can peek at a time.
I'll peek.
Yeah, yeah.
We will peek.
He has the armor.
He has one shot.
Fuck me.
Jump again, you little bitch.
Guys, I have 56 health.
56 damage.
Nice job.
I'm contributing.
Alright, what we're going to do here, guys.
Can you see this little cliff here?
Late game.
We're going to go to this cliff here late.
Okay?
We're going to literally walk out left.
We're going to walk into the front door.
And we're going to go out to the other side.
We're going to have to go pretty early though.
Because we can't fucking get killed.
Fucking through storm.
I believe.
Wait, is there a he shield?
Because we can have that one second he shield.
No, they do the tournament.
Oh, it's tournament mode.
We got to wait six seconds.
We're going to go now.
Go now.
Go to the cliff.
Jump to the cliff.
Jump to the cliff side.
Right here.
I'm here.
Come here.
We're good.
We're going to look left.
We're going to look left immediately.
Look at these kids.
They're going to try to shoot us.
They're going to be kids right above us too.
We're good.
We're so good.
Just stare left.
Someone stare left.
I'm staring.
We're going to walk in late.
We can't really do much here.
Oh my god.
How is there six teams still alive?
There's a team on my right.
On here.
I'm shooting.
We're good.
Shoot left.
Just don't let them kill us right now.
Tempo is not shooting left.
He's doing good.
It's fine.
If someone walks behind us, they're idiots.
They shouldn't.
Yeah, I'm watching behind us.
Look here.
They're looking.
Yeah, they're looking.
No, bro.
Right when I said...
I know.
I said they're looking.
Why did you stop looking?
I threw.
Of course I threw.
And I got wounded.
The moment they stopped looking.
I saw.
I saw like a fucking car selfman.
They pushed.
The timing.
And now my camera fell.
Now my camera's on the floor.
My whole setup just fell.
Bro, wait.
I think today's just not your day.
Oh my god.
He died to me.
Oh man.
Guys, it's okay.
We got six guys.
That's a lot of points.
Oh, what are the points?
That's... and we got six.
We got six guys.
Nice roll, guys.
Guys, you fucking threw that, man.
I'm sick to my stomach, dude.
Okay, we're back.
We were back.
I have to go pee like every 15 minutes.
Why?
What's...
That's not healthy.
That's not healthy at all.
There might be something wrong.
I'm on a bunch of energy drinks.
I just have to keep peeing.
What?
God.
Bro, you must be super dehydrated.
That is not healthy.
Top six is not bad.
How did I not get one?
Top six is pretty decent.
That's eight points.
We're at eight now.
Yay, eight points!
Yay!
We got eight points in total.
Wait, how do you...
Wait, you are ass.
Ban him!
Why?
What did I do to knock?
Do it!
No buzz!
What did I do to knock, bro?
Okay.
Where's Greek?
Okay, Greek is team 14.
Team 14.
Team 14 got 19 plays with zero kills!
So, they're actually last last!
Oh my god, they're probably molding right now.
I'm so happy.
Bro, they're actually last last!
We're not last!
Because we got points with placements!
That's so good for us, dude.
Yeah.
No fucking box right now, TT.
My whole camera service is fucked.
This is crazy, dude.
Alright, new goal.
Not last.
That's my new goal.
That wasn't last.
We did it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got it.
As long as Greek's team does not have a winning game, we're fine.
I'm saying.
That's why I really care about them.
Yeah.
Is them not winning?
Your roommate doesn't win at all.
Is that what you want?
I can't explain to you.
Right when I looked away, they pushed.
Yeah, I know.
I was like, where did you go?
I looked back and you were gone.
I fucked it up so bad.
I was like, where did you go?
Where did my other person go?
And he said this is the only angle that matters.
And then I immediately just looked.
Right when I said that.
That is insane.
I completely blacked out because I just saw a full three man in the back.
I did like 800 damage to him too.
That was crazy.
I got too horny.
I just wanted this.
Alright, Wishes, top six.
Next one's top five.
Yeah?
Is that how math works?
Next one's top five?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got this.
Okay.
Command center with Snipes team.
Jurassic is open.
There's two teams contesting Stormcatcher.
Jurassic's terrible, bro.
So do we want Jurassic bald?
Oh my god, Jurassic's so bad.
Isn't like Jurassic like way worse loot than anywhere else we can go?
But on this map that I googled, on this map that I googled, it has a beacon.
That means we get a beacon.
So we're not contesting that Jurassic if we go there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because somehow we still didn't have a beacon at Geyser.
Let's do it.
Alright.
If we go Jurassic and there's a beacon at command center?
Well, no.
There's a team command center too.
Yeah, that's fair.
Okay, so Jurassic.
No, no, no, no.
Wait, wait.
What?
What happened?
I was gonna do the same thing.
Can we?
Is there a crafter at Jurassic?
I mean, Temba, we got nothing out of you doing that.
Yeah, we got beacon.
I still scanned Harvester's beacon when I ran back.
But if we have beacon here, we don't need it.
So let's see first.
Alright, alright.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then if not, I'll go third Stormcatcher, scan beacon, and then die.
Oh, yeah, yeah, because we have crafter.
We have crafter.
Yeah, and two teams are contesting as Stormcatcher.
So we're good.
It's the exact same plan.
Yep.
This is it.
Okay, wait.
Okay.
So what are the legends?
What are the legends that are...
Wait.
Because like...
our strategy also relies on what legends we can play, too.
I'm locked in.
No, I think like letting Temba be free actually made our gameplay so much better.
I think so, too.
I didn't have to worry about him.
Yeah, we don't have to worry about him.
We just have to let him... we just have to free him, then roam around.
Then do what he wants to do.
Oh, man.
It's okay, guys.
We're not last.
We are.
Okay, so GoTrivalz is raiding and also just giving 25 subs to whoever, a random streamer that's involved.
That's pretty cool.
Oh!
Ballistic Wraith Rev Valk Cat Mirage.
Okay, so clearly Wake should play Valk.
Oh no wait, there's a Fuse in there too.
Clearly Wake!
I think a unanimous decision for the squad is that Tempo's not on Valks.
Yes.
The moment Tempo was on Valk, we got 20th!
You're so right, you're so right.
Okay, and then Tempo will play Catalyst, right?
And then I'll be Mirage for the crafting.
I think... you're playing Mirage, Foggy?
Or should I play Fuse?
We need the craft though!
No!
No, you're right, you're right.
Are you comfortable on Mirage?
Oh yeah, I'm very comfortable on Mirage.
Why are you so comfortable?
I do not believe her.
Why do I not trust what she's saying?
I'm so comfortable.
Oh yeah, I'm comfortable.
I'm so comfortable on Mirage.
Oh yeah, I'm so comfortable.
Don't worry.
When you see my banner, you'll understand.
It also has zero kills?
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Look at my Season 5 win.
That was like three years ago.
I'm so comfortable on Mirage when it was Season 5.
When it was...
Season 5?
Season 21?
Check my Mirage.
Yup.
Check it.
I'll check it when we go in the...
I'm actually so mad at myself it's unbelievable that I looked away.
What is wrong with me?
What am I doing?
I can't blame Tempo.
You know, I can't blame him.
No, you can't.
You can't blame him.
What happened?
Yeah, me looking away.
I fucked up, you know what I mean?
I got too horny.
I just got way too horny for the squad.
I saw Red.
Woah, what the fuck?
You're like...
Your mic.
What the fuck?
Oh no, it's all going downhill.
It's all going downhill.
Oh my god.
I still don't know why Nob called me ass.
Did you check my Mirage stats?
Oh, there we go.
No, are you live right now?
No, check that.
Just press F.
What?
F.
I've never seen that before.
Oh my god, you have 3600 kills?
I do have so many Mirages.
Look at my wins.
Wait, what's Mirage's thing?
I can't believe you played that character that much.
Only in Season 5 and then I never touched Mirage again.
I was on the Mirage leader points for Season 5.
Oh my god.
I was.
I had the most... I was like top 10 Mirage players because of my Mirage wins.
I was like number one in Canada because I had the most Mirage wins in Season 5.
Who the fuck are you?
Why are you moving?
I had the most Mirage wins in Canada in Season 5.
Because I had the most Mirage wins.
It's legit.
I remember because I thought it was so funny when I looked at the leaderboards.
I mean, you being top in Mirage wins is pretty fucking funny to me.
I'm expecting a carry.
A Mirage carry.
In Canada.
The score is updated.
One sec, I'll be right back real quick.
It's not updated.
That's right.
Number one in Canada.
That's all that matters.
I was top 10 in the world for Mirage wins.
We're in 18th.
Guys, we're doing it!
We're doing it.
Alright, we need to get to top 10, ok?
Ok, I just want...
If we get 17th or 16th, I'd be happy.
That's really it.
No, we need to get around top 10.
This is sort of telling me how it's going to be in CC right now.
I'm sort of having a feeling where we're at at CC.
Hey, CC will be much easier.
I'm back, how we looking?
CC people actually scrim.
CC will be easier.
Oh I think CC does it easier.
People in CC actually scrim!
I think Tebow is right, I think CC does it.
They shoot like they're not playing with a mouse.
Yeah, like Doki, you're going to tap strafe on kids.
I'm going to tap strafe on kids.
They're going to pull from a daycare and do a Super Glide.
Yep.
On the play sets.
Oh my god.
In challenge circuit, even I should be able to 1v3 some teams.
You know what I'm saying?
That's the vibe that I have.
Do I have the confidence to do so?
No.
Yes.
This is our warm up.
This is it.
Hey, remember, Jurassic, if there's no beacon, I'm gonna go third stormcatcher.
Alright.
And steal their beacon.
Yeah, I mean, for some reason, this is like an actual unbelievable strat we're doing and it's working.
So, we just got top six with you landing Harvester and us landing Geyser.
I'm not really sure I've ever seen that strat before in any level of Apex Legends.
My mom's calling me.
One second.
Yeah, what's up, mom?
Hey, mom!
Mom.
Hi, mom.
Doki says hi.
What'd you say?
Hey, mom.
You think I'm better than your son?
Doki wonders if you think she's better than me at Apex.
I don't know.
Bro, she doesn't even feel like...
Bro, I'm the best thing that's ever happened!
She's awful.
No, no, no, no.
What?
Well, now you have to come to land.
I'm the best thing that ever happened to Apex.
Alright, we're in game.
I love y'all.
Yup, yup, yup.
Bye, mom.
Love you.
Oh, my God.
I got the... Mom, I love you.
Wait, who am I playing?
Who am I playing?
You're playing Valk.
Of course you're playing Valk.
I'm Kat.
I'm Mirage.
Where's Valk?
Valk is top right.
I knew it.
I knew I was special.
Alright,
let's lock it in.
Yeah, we got this.
Yeah, I got this.
Tempo's not on.
I'm the character that I'm on, which is great.
Yeah.
Look at it!
409 Season 5 Apex wins!
Why is it gold?
Why is it like so... so like...
Yo, we have beacon and command center doesn't it?
Okay, then you have to land on it with us.
We're so good.
Yeah.
Now you actually land with us.
Wait, can we... we can't...
We can't do the double scan thing, right?
No, it doesn't work.
You can scan right now and then scan afterwards too.
I mean, there's no point in scanning now and then.
We just wait.
Yeah, yeah, you just gotta wait.
I'm just gonna land here, I guess.
Sure, buddy.
Wait, why is that team right above us seem very close?
Wait, what?
Where?
What?
That's not my decoy, by the way, because I forgot to use my decoy.
Mirage player.
You should have sent it at Echoey's curious time.
Yeah, that's true.
You should have just fucking scared somebody.
Just send them all into command.
Good game last game though, guys.
Actually, like really good job.
Yeah, yeah.
The little pig was...
The little pig was definitely the thing to do.
Yeah, yeah, I agree.
Good job.
Proud of you.
Yeah, no problem.
Oh my god.
I have my heirloom too.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
This is one of those heirlooms I actually paid money for.
Do you like that heirloom?
Yes, I think the Marge statue is like one of the best heirlooms they have.
Solid.
Yeah, like I love the animations on it.
Uh oh.
I heavily relate to Marge.
You love yourself that much?
I have a great story.
I carry the statue around.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Actual goals, you know?
Yeah, 100%.
Tabo, hit that beacon, baby.
Let's see where we're going.
Don't forget I have alcohol to your suit.
Did you loot this already?
You loot this house?
I did, yeah.
Oh, okay.
I'm going back then.
You're good.
I'm going to hit this...
Oh, we can get a good spot now.
We can get a good spot, guys.
Okay.
I'm going to immediately hit this goddamn old DxL and we're going to get going.
Okay, we're going to start moving to the far one.
Okay, guys.
Deal?
Alright, I'm here.
Through here, right?
You guys are coming back this way?
Yeah, I'm going to come back to you.
There's a disruptor here with an alternator.
Oh, shit.
That's probably the better one I have.
It's okay.
No big deal.
Oh, okay.
I could have got back.
No, no, no.
It's right below you.
Oh, really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where?
Oh, down here?
Yeah.
It's next to an alternator.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, you're right.
What the fuck?
Yeah, I told you.
Oh, my God.
That's fucking coded.
Thank you.
See?
I'm a good person.
Yeah, sure.
Alright, I was kidding.
Whoa!
I'm going to have ulti in a little bit.
We're going to probably ulti first, then evac.
We want to get... for this zone, I think we want to get one of these two houses back here.
Oh, yeah.
If it's open.
We're going to keep moving up.
We're going to go through power one a little bit more, then we're going to back ulti right here.
Up top.
I don't know how far we can actually go, though.
I'm right behind you.
I still need to see a...
Like a scope.
We need like one more.
Yeah, I have zero scope.
Wait, we can grab this thing, right?
Yeah, we have to grab the...
Yeah.
We'll definitely do that.
We need that red band.
You need purple energy?
Purple?
Yeah, I do.
I do.
Nice.
You didn't even have energy again.
Wait, I don't even see this looted.
In an ulti, call it reduce.
I was revived with health.
Okay.
Yeah, I was revived with health.
There's a pack on our right.
Did we want to stop for that or no?
No, I think we just keep going.
No, I think we have to get a zone.
Someone definitely landed here, though.
Yeah, they definitely did.
Called it, yeah.
Don't worry.
My mirage clone will distract them.
Good shit.
We're going to try to get the left side tree and ulti over, okay?
I keep forgetting to scan packs, bro.
I think you remember to do that.
It's a fucking gold master.
I found it.
We need that shit in this one.
Yeah, it's fine.
We're going to go to tree, then ulti over.
My god, I have two, four, I have five nades.
What the fuck am I going to do with five nades?
I don't know.
Throw them?
We have to live long enough for that.
The chances of you throwing five is pretty crazy.
All right, ready?
Oh my god, we're so... wouldn't it be funny if you guys shot?
We would have been so far out.
That would be so funny.
He got shot.
I feel like Teppo is still running.
This could be the end of us or the start of us.
Yes, sir.
Velko.
All right, we're going to try to go back side.
Just let me know if you see anyone.
We're going for this building back here.
Well, there's obviously somebody there.
No, I'm the building in the back.
Yep, there is.
There is.
Oh, there is.
We're going to go back to the terrace.
We're good.
We're good here.
All right.
We're valid.
This is so easy to play.
We're chilling.
Fucking... Oh my god.
Oh, you're good.
You're good.
I'm so good.
Shut up.
We're using shit.
We're chilling.
We're so good.
Behind us?
Yeah, like driving behind.
In the open.
I want to open this bin.
Let's see.
Teppo, honest question.
Ready?
Like giving your input.
Do you think that this tunnel is better for us or staying on staircase is better?
I honestly have no idea.
Ideal.
It's up to you, ideal.
Zero idea.
I think we're going to stay here to be honest.
Okay.
Can I be playing tunnel without a fucking like actual good defensive character other than Teppo?
I think I was pretty sure.
I have like 18 nades for some reason.
All right.
I have like two syringes.
I haven't found single syringes anywhere.
You bitch, bro.
Don't shoot me.
What?
Wait, my game lagged.
Wait, what?
Behind us.
I have a glitch.
Okay.
I can't heal.
I literally can't heal.
I have a glitch.
Wait, what?
Every time I heal, my screen goes black.
Guys, come back to me.
Come back to me.
Okay.
I'm here.
I just threw 18 nades at them because...
Yeah, you're good.
You're good.
My game is fucked.
You have to play slow.
Okay.
So you can't do that at all?
I would have come back in.
In my deal, it shows like a...
Are you cheating?
Destroyer?
No, an arm in my face.
I have a whole arm in my face.
You have a whole arm?
Wait.
But you still can't heal, but you just... it's just a visual bug.
I can't see anything in my heal.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I'm hiding.
My whole chat's been caught.
Oh, no.
Destroyer.
You're cheating.
I'm cheating.
Destroyer.
Destroyer's here, baby.
Don't worry.
How's in our tournament?
Destroyer.
Yeah.
Why me?
He has like so many people watching him.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Why me, man?
Yeah.
You want publicity?
Go for hell.
Yeah.
You'll get it.
You'll get all that publicity.
So many tweets.
Yeah.
So many engagement.
Think of the engagement, Destroyer.
Oh, my God.
The impressions.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
All the impressions.
I don't think I want to peek anymore, guys.
I don't have a lot of heels.
Good idea.
Wait.
Landing?
Landing.
Tunnel.
Cracked one.
How are you guys peeking in?
Oh, boy.
Did we get chopper?
Where?
The left.
The right side.
Oh, okay.
They're going to be on silo.
They have to watch out.
Yeah.
I'm just going to stay down here in the stairs.
You're good.
I'm going to show a little prep so we don't get sent on.
My fucking Mirage clone.
Oh, my God.
The fact that I can't see anything is crazy, bro.
I have a technical problem.
Okay.
I have two T -shirts, two quads.
Yeah.
He's just going to stand here and he'll let us know.
Actually, good comms.
Wait.
Yeah.
They'll be like, what is this Mirage doing in the open?
This is going to fuck me over so hard if we actually play.
This will do me so bad.
I literally can't heal with my gunfight.
It's crazy.
Bro, they have...
Why nerf us?
Yeah, why nerf us?
Yeah.
What is this?
...
If you rejoin, do you think that would help?
Bro, if he does that, he's going to fucking...
We have a team fight.
I think if I leave it doesn't fix anything.
I think it's just an official bug in my game.
Also I don't want to risk it because what if it just gets sent on and I'm just gone.
I'd rather just play with it.
Shoot my clone!
He's literally having a fun time in the open.
He's real.
I swear.
Imagine that's just you and they're not shooting you because they think it's a clone.
Oh my god!
I should... do you guys want to try that?
Yeah, you should do it right now.
Okay, okay.
Never mind.
Read through it immediately.
I'm not going to peek anymore.
I'm stupid.
Bro, how do you know which one is a clone?
I'm seeing a bright yellow thing in my face.
This is fire.
Where am I?
I can't see.
The syringe is half!
My screen is covered in half with the syringe.
It's ridiculous, bro.
Why does no one want to shoot me?
Please, you're not up there.
Don't shoot her.
I don't know if that guy is actually trying to shoot my clone or not.
I saw straight bullets.
How is my clone traveling so far?
He shot him!
He got bamboozled 50 meters away.
Get on, nerd.
Okay, do you think this is a Mirage clone?
Are they going to shoot me?
Shoot her for the scan, please.
If I die, I blame Wig because I'm doing something dumb.
I'm down for that.
I'm not getting shot at.
It works!
That is fucking crazy, bro.
They actually let me just run around.
No way.
I peeped my head through a second and got lit the fuck up.
Alright, hopefully, guys, a minute left.
We'll see the damage you're on, Zell.
I think it's going right towards us.
I don't know if they're shooting me or what.
They are?
Wait, they are!
No!
Okay, now I'm not doing that again.
We're good.
I have one shield cell left because I fucked around.
Don't hit me.
Okay.
I fucked around a little, so now I have one shield cell left.
Nice.
How many of you have Zembo?
I have one.
Here's a pet.
I have one five now.
I am two five.
I'm one two five.
Alrighty, alrighty, alrighty, alrighty.
Let's see, let's see.
Come on, baby.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
I'm real.
Chat, we think if the zone comes here or what?
I don't think so.
Okay, guys, come on.
Yeah, I see you.
Let's see it pull to the other side!
Oh, Victoria!
Let's see it pull!
Oh!
It's not bad, it's not bad for us.
Wait, we're so good, we're so good, we're so good!
Wait.
Is anyone in armory?
Wait, we're so good.
We're gonna get sent on though.
We're so good.
Did we just play backside rock over here now?
Isn't there people there?
I don't think so.
I mean, we could.
It's all good for now, it's all good for now.
Okay.
We're gonna hold out southwest.
We're gonna literally hold out southwest.
That's the goal.
Oh.
These guys need to die on the rotation end.
Let's do it.
Oh, I stuck my decoy in there.
I thought that was you.
Okay, so southwest is gonna be our number one enemy here, guys.
Okay.
And they're gonna start picking us soon too.
Okay, I don't know if I wanna waste some meds though.
I'm not sure if I wanna waste these meds.
Yeah, you bad.
Yeah, Tempo, stop peeking, I think.
Yeah, definitely stop peeking, Tempo, for sure.
Don't worry, I'm gonna see if I can grab intel.
I'm just peeking so I can make sure these guys know that we're looking at them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, me too.
Wait, are they actually sniping my decoy and missing?
I think they are.
They did.
I just watched it happen.
Don't come this way, we're watching you.
They know we have to go this way, that's why.
They can go the other way.
Should we not go to the rock now, or wait?
They're triangle thinking.
Nah, they're gonna stay here for now.
I don't really wanna jump too early and then we just get fucking shit on.
And we stop Valko.
Yeah, we do, yeah.
I just don't know if anyone's back there and we Valko'd and then they take our spot.
Forwarding to the next ring.
That's the only problem.
Yeah, that's true.
It smells kinda like...
Alright, let's see where they go.
Whatever.
Let's keep looking over here.
Just don't take too much damage.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Someone dropped down here.
I don't know if it was that team.
They're going left.
I think they're leaving us.
They're leaving us.
Yeah, they did.
They went up the tunnel.
It's fine.
That's only two that left that I saw.
All three, all three, all three there.
All three?
Yeah, yeah, I just saw.
We're doing it.
Look at this decoy.
I just got bamboozled.
Oh my god, you got bamboozled too?
Where's the care pack at?
I need to scan.
I hear a pack.
To our right.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's fine.
We're good.
Yeah, you wanna do it?
I'll do it back, bitch.
I don't care.
That clone didn't really go anywhere.
Yeah.
There's a right team back rock.
Knock that guy.
Holy shit, get shit on.
Okay.
I got shot from behind.
There's someone behind that rock.
They're behind the rock now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
We're good.
I'm gonna kill this guy.
Wait, he's sliding down here.
Oh, no.
He went into that tunnel.
Let's see where Zundas goes.
Zundas, pull back rock.
Where can we go here?
This is so bad for us actually.
Holy fuck.
Well, we can't go behind this because there's a team there now.
We can't play silo.
I don't think either.
Silo will just get shot at.
Yeah, they're all the way behind.
I mean, we have Velko.
We can Velko here.
Where the fuck did he go?
I don't know.
We have to help Mary somewhere.
I think we just walk in slow and just go to silo here.
We just walk in slow.
I'm trying to kill everyone that's inside.
That's all we can do.
Just play slow.
Don't take any damage.
Let these teams fight inside.
We just third party and walk up.
Stay slow.
All right.
We're gonna play for the height.
We'll see if they fight inside.
They should.
Team flying in.
We're good.
Yep, just get some shots down.
We're all good.
Oh, they made a walk?
Oh, they catwalked.
Yeah, they catwalked.
That's fine.
Yeah, we're good.
They're doing quick.
We're fighting whoever's there.
Yeah, just keep playing here.
Just keep playing there.
You guys be playing there.
I'm gonna move up a little bit.
Just hold space.
All right.
We're looking.
One drop down right here.
I'm looking.
Two drop down.
Two, yeah.
No armor 23.
Yeah, just keep looking there, guys.
I'm looking at somebody else right now.
You guys keep looking there.
They're not peeking us right now.
I'm looking at you guys.
You guys are good.
They went up.
They're going up.
Yeah, we're good.
They're on the ramp.
I think I'm gonna get rest of them.
We need to focus these guys.
Hardcore left side.
I'm looking.
I'm gonna kill.
I got Mirage bamboozled.
Oh my god.
Does anyone have light ammo?
No, I don't.
I can't spare any.
I knew I do it here.
I'm gonna use it.
I'm gonna use it right now.
Here.
Ramp, ramp, ramp, ramp.
They're shooting ramp.
Good point.
Yeah.
Keep walking up slow.
We're good.
Keep shooting ramp.
Just keep shooting ramp again.
Shooting ramp.
Yeah, just keep looking left side.
We're good.
Just keep looking.
Nice job, Ducky.
You're doing great.
We're gonna move in slowly.
All right.
Wait, wait, wait.
There's a team right below.
There's a team right below us.
Come to me.
I'm here.
Wait, wait, wait.
Temba, put Q's over here, on the wall.
Below me.
Yeah, shoot left.
Shoot left.
Yeah.
Oh, right.
Left side.
Right behind us.
There's a Mirage, there's a Mirage.
Two, two, two, two.
Crouch, crouch, crouch.
Dippo, no.
We got this, buddy.
Jump down if you need.
Play left.
I have a tree.
You're a tree.
I don't move.
It's just a duo behind us, man.
They came out of nowhere.
The Valk is right in front of me.
Pretend you don't exist.
It's okay.
You're doing great.
Don't do anything.
Do not do anything.
They're tunnel visioning right now.
Top 10!
Good job!
Nice!
We got top 10!
Let's try.
Damn it.
They actually look...
We got top 10!
We'll take it.
We got top 10 and a kill.
That's fine.
I'm gonna pee again.
What?
You got what?
He has to urinate again.
What?
He has to pee again.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
I have no idea.
That's not healthy.
That is 100% not healthy.
You're peeing every 15 minutes.
I agree.
Nice job, though.
We did a good job.
We just killed that duo.
We could actually be alive right now.
They just came out of nowhere.
I thought they were not rotating to us.
I don't know why they did that.
I thought they were going inside.
It worked out, but it is what it is.
Temple definitely has a bladder problem right now.
For sure.
I'm nervous.
How is he nervous?
Why the fuck is he nervous?
How the fuck is he nervous?
He's the diamond three in the game.
That's what I'm saying.
It's okay.
As long as...
We got top 10 plus one point.
As long as Greek got not top 10 plus one, I'm so happy.
Yeah, yeah.
That's all we have to worry about.
That's all we need.
That's all I care about.
We got the vibes.
That's all we need.
The vibes.
Wow.
I see the spy for the wraith.
I'm checking the wraith play right now.
Wait, did he get that?
He tried.
No, he did.
That would have been so fucking funny.
That would have been so nice if he did that.
Look at all the rats out here, man.
There's so many rats.
Oh my god, look at all these rats.
That could have been tempo.
What?
I know.
I can't believe they saw you.
You could have been free.
Yeah, I'm lucky and surprised.
Me too.
They should have been so distracted with the people above me.
Honestly, Dembo, did you have cat wall there?
Yes.
We should have cat walled ourselves, to be honest.
We go to that pillar and we just cat wall off the other side.
That's my bad.
I should have told you that.
I forgot we were playing cat.
We didn't use any of our ults, except for that one bell.
I got shot so fast, I couldn't even ult.
No, that's not your fault.
That's my bad.
I should have told 100% tempo to cat wall us off, so teams can't push us.
Yeah, cat wall behind us.
Exactly.
It's okay.
The next game.
Now we know.
Did we get a kill?
Yeah, we got one kill.
I got to kill the Lombo.
Nice.
I like after that first game, Temple hasn't got a kill for more subs.
That poor Valk.
What the fuck?
Wait, wait.
That means we're at 11?
There's no way.
He tried.
That Valk definitely tried.
They did their best.
Hey, listen.
10th place, one kill.
Not awful.
Yeah, yeah.
It's pretty decent.
Pretty fucking decent, guys.
You know, it means we're better than Greek.
Okay, let's check Greek score.
Oh no.
I think you just won.
Imagine.
No.
Don't say that.
Don't.
No.
No, we needed him to not win a game.
Please no.
Oh no.
Okay, it's not Greek.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Wait, peeps was below us too.
Oh no.
Damn it.
Wait, wait.
Where's Greek?
Greek's 14.
Where's 14?
Where is 14?
14.
He got zero kills.
14th place.
Zero points.
We're at 6.
We're at 11.
Nice.
Okay.
Where's Jent?
Greek's team had zero points.
We're still fine.
Yeah, Jent's team's 6.
He got 9th with 2.
A little bit of a lost.
Is he gonna pass us?
No, no.
He was already past us.
But we were gonna...
Okay, so we're only 3 points away from Jent.
We're at 19.
It's okay.
We're not...
Greek just needs a really, really good game to... Reptarium Greek?
Okay, we just need to beat your roommate.
That's all I want, bro.
That's all I want.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
That's all I want, bro.
That's all I need.
Okay, hopefully these next lessons are good for us.
We definitely don't need support, to be honest.
We haven't used it once.
To be fair.
Yeah.
I'm gonna go Fuse if she wants to.
I'm gonna go with the controller.
Yeah, we'll see.
We'll see what... If we... yeah.
I think the next one's like pretty weird.
I think it's... let me see.
I think... I know they put it there.
I think it's...
Uh...
Oh, they're typing it right now.
Let's wait.
It's like 6 Skirmisher or some shit like that.
It's like majority of Skirmish.
I think it was.
Wait, which one's Skirmisher?
6 Assault.
It's 6 Assault this time around?
I have no idea.
I was making it up.
Oh.
What did Clara say?
Can y'all...
Okay, yes.
Who is it?
Assault, controller, support.
Okay, so we have Ash, MadMaggie, Ballistic, Watson, Rampart, Loba, Mirage, Conduit.
Holy fuck.
Um... My god.
They really saved the worst for last.
I like that.
Uh... Alright, so who are you gonna play?
I'm Fused.
There's no... Oh, there's Fused.
Okay.
Who is she gonna play?
I'm back.
Wait.
Watson or Rampart?
Wait, what's the... What's the thing?
It's Ash and Maggie.
Oh, I can do Conduit.
Alright, I'm down.
Oh, that sounds great.
Yeah, I can do Conduit.
And maybe I'll just do Ash for the TP.
Alright, cool.
Down, down, down, down.
Yeah, so we got Ash.
Wait, is Temple gonna play Watson or Rampart?
Oh, actually, yeah.
I can play Watson.
Yeah, play Watson.
This is the last game.
As long as Grief dies before us, then we've, like, established that we're better than Grief's team.
Grief, you gotta go out last, man.
No, do you know what's even... I can't go out last.
We have no pro player on our team, but we're still above a pro player team.
Yeah, true.
If you think about it that way.
Like you're spinning.
Yeah.
We literally have...
Why are you a genius?
.
We basically won.
Any team that's below us is embarrassing.
Alright, let's pass a few more then.
That is fucking for sure.
And that's gonna be one team, which is Grief's.
Yeah, it's gonna be one team.
Is it funnier if it's just one team?
And, by the way, in Reptar had first pick.
In Reptar had first pick.
True.
I'm gonna be regretting that game.
Alright, we'll see what happens, dude.
Alright, so I'm gonna go Ashe, then you go Watson, then you go Conduit?
Yeah, I go Conduit.
This is our sweatiest comp so far.
This is our actual real comp so far.
It's like the only real one that makes sense.
Alright, I swapped.
I'm back in.
This is it.
We're gonna...
My goal is, as long as we're above Grief's team, that's all I want.
That's all I want.
That's really all we want right now.
Yeah.
Yeah, warm up's done, guys.
Five warm up games.
That's all we needed.
Yeah.
That's all we need.
If Peep can go from 19th to a win with 8, we should be able to do that.
We should be able to do that.
Okay, but the thing is...
The thing that separates us from Peep is that all three of us are plat rank right now.
are plat rank right now.
Wait...
Plat?
Rooting for minus downfield.
Diamond?
Raise Pred.
Yeah, so like, I don't know.
I don't...
Our team, like, you know...
We got this.
Our team has to be like...
We're definitely the team of the people.
Yeah, we're the people's squad.
The amount of copium we're on right now is unreal.
We're the vibe team, guys.
We're the team that everyone likes, dude.
We are!
We can be multiple things!
Just not good?
Just not good.
Everything but good?
Can you really say that?
Can you say that we're a good team with a straight face?
Yeah.
Only you can, Temple!
You're the only one!
He's the only one that has like...
is like, actually delusional.
He's the only one.
I like it, though.
We need that, though.
We need somebody that's not in reality.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, well...
Hmm.
Alright, this is our sweatiest comp, bro.
We win this one.
There's no way.
Yeah.
We warmed up for like, whatever the game.
Doesn't matter.
It was the last one.
We got this.
Petition to play another Storm Point over Olympus.
Low key down for that.
To be honest.
I'll let the dude do.
Petition to reset score.
Oh my god, so real?
No, we play Olympus?
Yeah.
We're definitely a team.
I know.
We're a team.
We're...
Twitch Rivals and CEO of Twitch.
All I'm saying is that...
Wig, I don't know why, but when you're headlining a Twitch Rivals, Right.
Really, everything goes against you.
Not everything.
Not yet.
Not every... No, not everything though.
It's not about winning.
Okay?
It's really about...
It's not?
Wait, then why did you argue about me about that before when I said it wasn't about winning?
I'm trying to be positive now.
I did point my motivations all the way through the floor.
So you know what I mean?
Like now it's about...
So now it's not about winning.
No, no, of course.
Bias.
You know what I'm saying?
Now it's about...
Now it's not about winning.
Alright.
Exactly.
Well, we're up good and we haven't started yet.
Of course it's about winning.
But when we start doing bad, then it's all about the friends.
I can't believe our first game was our peak.
That was actually the game where we had the most kills.
We have 11 points.
Pretty good.
Just need 7.
For what?
7 for what though?
That's a lot of points.
8 points to get out of bottom 5.
We got 11 points just from 5 games.
I don't know.
8 points seems like a 5 game scenario.
You know what?
Are we leaving...
letting Tempo roam free again?
Wait, where are we?
No, I can't.
There's no place to roam to.
We're in Turbine.
Yeah, but like...
If you survive as a solo...
Oh, wait.
If we're in Turbine, I can land Waterfall.
Yeah.
Yeah, we should let him roam free.
Should we do it?
What?
Let Tempo roam free again for last game.
I'm so down.
Okay, actually Tempo, don't even come back to us.
What's the...
What's the butthole POI?
The butthole POI?
The Turbine?
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, fuck.
Rift?
The giant...
What?
Bro, Tempo, you organized the rifts.
Oh, Cammon.
Cammon.
Hammon?
It has a giant thingy that you can go in.
Okay, do we let Tempo roam free and not come back to us?
And then he can try and solo rat.
Yeah, I gotta go find a beacon.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
I'm so down.
Okay, Tempo, don't come back to us.
Okay, do you get a beacon in Turbine?
No.
I don't think so.
I'm gonna go steal Hammon.
Okay, this is...
This is the game.
This is the game where we get 10 points.
This is the game where Tempo will rat until second place or some shit.
Yeah, that's double our points then.
Well, I should pick a small person.
We already established our characters.
What do you mean you should pick a small person?
What the fuck, dude?
Let's do it.
Now we got this.
Ash, I'm Ash.
Yeah, you're Ash.
I am Conduit.
And Tempo is...
We just gotta trick someone into picking a character that's not there and then they get Mind Spy.
Yeah, but they're gonna restart the game.
True.
Mind Spy.
They're just gonna restart the game unless they are stubborn enough.
Oh, there we go.
Give me Ash!
Oh fuck, I just broke my controller.
We're good.
Give me Ash!
I'm locked in.
I'm so locked in right now.
We're so locked in.
We're here.
We're ready.
Alright, my face is in my screen.
Oh, hell yeah, baby.
I wish I was your screen right now.
Let's go!
Bro.
Bro, what?
Can you repeat that way?
Alright, here we go.
Do we have anything in Turbine?
We have nothing in Turbine.
Let's go.
We have a ring console for Tempo to scan.
We do?
Yeah!
We don't.
Yeah, yeah.
You're gonna go to Hammond.
I gotta wait for the team to land in Hammond.
And then I gotta steal their top loot.
Someone's actually taking Hammond?
God.
I don't know.
Is that person landing top Hammond?
Hey, why are you still with us, Tempo?
I forgot about the shrap 30 seconds after we formulated the block.
Sorry, I was watching the other team.
We're good.
Too late now.
Tempo, why are you still here?
I can't even steal your loot.
We literally knocked him out.
We're talking about the strat.
How did you forget?
I was... I don't know.
You're... I love you both so much.
I hope you don't mind.
Don't worry.
I turned around in that one game.
Yeah, yeah.
We're the team of the people.
We're the team of the people, guys.
Remember.
This has to be fucking somewhere near us, dude.
Like, this needs to be near us.
There's just no way it's not.
It has to be somewhere fucking close.
It just has to be.
Where is a beacon that we can hit?
Power grid.
That's not good for us, actually.
That is not good for us.
We should not go there.
No, we should not go there.
I think we take a gamble here.
Okay?
Yeah.
And I think we go towards docks.
Okay.
I believe in your gambles.
We have nothing left to lose.
We're literally...
We have to believe.
No, we do.
We have something to lose.
We have to lose Greek, man.
We have one thing specifically that we can lose.
We have only one thing to lose.
There's a charge rifle right here, Tempo.
Oh, I got one.
Nice.
He has the one thing he needs.
Wasn't there a skull person somewhere?
Mmm.
On the lambo.
I don't know where the skull person was.
I have no idea.
I haven't seen one.
They dropped it off my repeater.
Where the fuck did I put my repeater?
Oh my god, I'm a mess right now.
Oh no.
No, you can't be a mess right now.
No.
I'm freaking out.
Don't freak out.
There's a repeater right here.
It's a hammer point.
Oh, here, here.
I found it.
I was like, good.
I'm moving.
I'm so focused on the zone now that I'm just like...
Alright, let's go towards Docks.
Anyone have an evac tower?
Any evac tower friends?
Nope.
I've only had a chance to look at one evac tower and we died really early on.
And the drop killed us.
Alright.
Ready?
Let's move on through, guys.
Let's do it.
Friendship.
Yay.
Hey, hey, hey.
It's not a little more exciting.
Yay.
Wall bounce.
I love it.
We're doing so well.
I don't know.
Alright, keep on moving, guys.
I'm not gonna look up.
No, we're good.
We're so good.
I'm not gonna look up.
I 100% just picked the wrong perk.
We're good.
I'm looking... Oh, whoa.
I hear an evac tower in front of us.
That's good.
On me, on me.
Literally right on us.
Yeah, like, on me, on me, on me.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
Back up, back up.
Keep moving, keep moving.
Okay, okay, okay.
They conda-queued.
I hear a fight to my left.
Yeah, yeah.
Just keep on coming, guys.
Alright, I'm going, I'm walking forward.
I'm walking forward.
They're taking the thing up now.
That's okay.
We're good.
We're good, we're good.
We're just chilling here.
We're gonna move up.
I just want these guys to leave.
We're good.
They're leaving, they're leaving.
Alright, they're leaving?
I think.
No, on me.
They're not leaving.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
What are they doing?
These guys are stressing me the fuck out.
Bamboozled.
Okay, come follow me, follow me, follow me.
You guys coming?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a... There's a Watsonfest.
There's a Watsonfest.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
We gotta send it, we gotta send it.
Believe in me, believe in me.
Believe in me.
I'm believing, I'm believing, I'm believing.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
We're good.
Come on.
Oh, you guys are believing!
We're good, I'm believing!
Okay, coming, coming, coming, coming!
We're good.
I'm climbing, I'm climbing, climbing, climbing!
We're good, just play slow.
We're vibing.
We could play this pillar too, if we need to.
We're okay, we're dead.
Okay, uh, I'm going to leave.
The pillar is safe.
Go to the pillar, go to the pillar!
Yeah, I'm dead.
I'm good on life.
I'm alive.
I'm gonna die.
I'm alive, I think.
I'm dead!
I think, I think, I'm alive, we're crowned alive!
Okay, I'm batting.
We're okay, just play slow.
Play slow.
Okay, there's a fence to our left here too.
We got a problem.
We got vibing.
Just vibed, guys.
We're so good.
Oh, I'm so good.
I feel so healthy.
We're so good.
We're so fine.
I feel very healthy right now.
I'm so vibing, it's not even funny, guys.
Oh my god.
I'm dead.
We're alive.
I'm good, guys.
No, no, no.
You're good.
I'm looking to my right.
I'm alive.
I'm dead.
We're okay, I think.
Oh, this is the... I don't know, man.
I don't feel very comfortable here.
I feel very exposed for some reason.
We're gonna wait for my ulti and try to go up here.
Okay.
On that house.
But you guys stay here.
I'm gonna...
There's people literally right here.
Oh my god.
What is this Mirage doing?
How is he able to sit out here, man?
I'm just saying there's people right here above me.
Okay, that's fine.
We're good.
We're vibing.
We're just...
We're good.
Just stay low.
Chill out.
Yeah, man.
I'm stressed the fuck out.
I'm so stressed out.
But we're not 20th.
We're not 20th.
Yeah, but we need to...
Wow, pro.
How are these kids able to peek this?
I'm so lost.
How people are able to do this.
It's okay.
We're good.
Tembo, you're good where you're at.
You're fine.
Tembo, move up more here.
Here, right?
One place low.
Tembo, just don't.
We're good, guys.
How are these teams able to do this to us?
I'm getting harassed.
Tembo, please save us.
How are they able to get these angles?
I'm getting harassed.
Why is no one here?
I'm getting harassed right now.
You're good.
I'm looking for you.
I'm pre-firing.
No one's there.
There's no safe.
There's no silver.
Tembo, gray fences, kid.
Don't fucking shoot them.
Gray fences, kid.
They don't shoot us.
Do I stay here?
Stay there.
Don't stay there.
Come on.
How are you getting shot?
Where are you getting shot from?
I don't know!
How is this possible?
No!
Everywhere I go...
There's hoes on us!
Dude, I'm so bad!
A building would be nice.
A building would be fantastic right now.
We just take the car and eat a building?
No, you guys stay here.
I'm gonna try to figure something out.
Stay here.
This team above us must have so much space.
That's why they're doing this.
There's no way they're able to... there's no way.
I'm so scared, man.
We're actually lowkey not awful.
Like I'm being honest.
I was literally in the worst spot possible.
No, no.
This spot where I'm at is good.
Okay, I'm... I'm okay now.
I'm not... I'm not panicking anymore.
Guys, I've calmed down.
I've calmed down.
Hell yeah!
Did you?
Guys, guys, you just threw up everywhere.
Guys, I'm chilling now, guys.
Guys, guys, I'm not anxious anymore.
I'm okay now.
I've calmed down.
After all that, I'm good.
I'm not stressed anymore, guys.
I think I feel like a better... I feel like a...
Much better person.
You know what?
Maybe this spot is doable.
You know?
I'm telling you right now, if we lay low, like you guys just don't peek, no one's gonna think someone's playing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, no, yeah, exactly.
Not all of these Watson fences.
Yeah.
Who the fuck would play here, bro?
Honestly.
Yeah, yeah.
Who the fuck put all these Watson fences there?
There's nobody here.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna be honest, guys.
If there's one thing I took today from all these games...
In order for challenges to work, I gotta step my eyes yelling out, holy fuck.
Oh my god.
I am rusty.
I think we all are.
We are all definitely rusty, I will admit.
Wait, okay.
I just wanna know, is Greek's team dead?
I hope.
Is that...
I haven't seen it.
I haven't seen 14 yet.
Oh, we haven't seen... No, fuck.
Okay, he's still alive.
So bad for us, guys.
That's so bad.
He's still alive.
We need to look at team 14.
The only issue here that I'm... The only issue we have, like, genuinely...
Is if this team above us just... The zone, like, pulls up more and they're the only team inside docks...
Then they could... Oh, they're not.
They're getting shot at.
That's good.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
That's good.
We're fine.
We're so healthy.
That's a great chat.
That's a great one.
Everybody knows we're here now, too.
So that's okay.
No, it's fine.
That's great.
We're creating presence now, right?
Now we want presence.
Yeah, and now we want presence.
Yeah.
Like Santa.
Yeah, I'm learning.
I'm learning from your IGL.
Now we want people to know we're here.
Good.
You're doing so good.
I'm sorry.
I'm just gonna stay here still.
I'm gonna stay here.
There's people all over the room.
To be fair though, we did get fucked over like pretty hard again.
Like every time.
I think like... I think everybody bullied us out of a good POI.
That's exactly what it is.
I think that's what happened.
Oh, my Ruchai.
Everybody just kicked us out.
They're like, okay, nice week, put Geyser.
They're like, uh, all right.
Yeah, they could have that.
They're like, nice week, put Geyser.
They're like, all right, we'll take that for them.
They're like, oh, it's nice week.
Yeah.
I think that's on there.
I mean...
They don't even have a pro on their team.
Yeah, they don't even have a pro.
They literally have a Plat 4 and a Diamond 3.
And another Plat.
They literally had three Plat players.
Okay, here's the moment of truth, guys.
Why is team 14 still?
Wait, but this is your tournament.
How did you let these people fucking...
Oh, my God.
The zone pulls back.
Okay, this is gonna be the craziest thing I ever said.
We should get middle of fight night.
Like, inside fight night?
Yes.
How do we run past everybody?
I mean, I get this vehicle, we queue in there.
Or I boost in there.
Okay, do we do it now?
Now?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Come with me, Donkey.
Come over here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get right where tempo is.
Okay.
I have an Ashport, but I think we should go for the Trident, because it's funnier.
Okay, I'm ready.
Jesus Christ.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Boost, boost, boost, boost.
Wait, it's only the boost.
Get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out.
No, I got to kill you.
It's a whole squad.
Why is there a whole squad there?
You run.
Get away, Donkey, get away.
I'm in.
You can crack this.
Run.
I'm getting punch already.
What?
Why is there a whole team?
I'm taking the port.
Oh, wait.
That's not it.
Why is there a whole team?
Is there a team in this?
I'm not taking a hold of that.
There is already a full team inside!
Wig, I don't think we should have done that, Wig.
Where is Wig?
Wait, where is he?
You live?
You might be able to craft that.
I'm alive, I'm alive, I'm alive.
Okay.
All I'm saying is that, Wig...
We're craftable.
I think you might have made the wrong decision.
I mean, why is there a full team with an Arcstar there?
Why?
Someone please tell me why.
That is unbelievable.
Wait, you have no white bats?
No!
You have zero?
We're like a turbine!
I have nothing!
How do you have no zero?
Wait, wait, wait.
You just gotta last...
until 14 dies.
14 dies!
Nothing matters anymore!
You did?
Nothing matters!
We're both green!
14 is dead, nothing matters!
Wait, wait, wait.
We can beat Deeds.
If you get...
12, 9, 7, 5.
If you get top 5, we beat Deeds.
Okay.
Second.
The person above us.
The person of the team above us.
If we beat...
Oh my god.
The fucking riskiest reload of your life.
After the audio play, there's no idea where I'm at.
You're listening to me right now.
You know, maybe we should not listen to something that was like, but it would be so funny.
Like maybe that's just not...
But content.
Yeah, but like, who else smiled during that?
No one else?
We did.
I got stuck.
I got hurt.
You got fucked over.
Wait, you got stuck or our car got stuck?
Because I got hit too.
I got stuck.
Oh, maybe our car got hit and all of us...
No, why are you peeking?
Why are you looking at me?
I didn't know if there was the inside button or if I'm going in there and scrapping.
You're literally...
Look at your heels!
The fact that you have the confidence to even look at somebody.
At least I was getting top 10.
I'm fucking dead in this next zone.
Don't look down, for sure.
You don't know that.
Oh.
You can craft us...
You can craft us in the north?
Oh...
Wait a minute.
Craft you?
Yay!
Wait, okay, if he crafts us, where is he going to rez?
No, you're telling me, that's not delusional?
That's not delusional?
Come on.
Where is he going to rez, Tempo?
I should realistically die to storm here, so I don't give deeds a kill.
Find a move.
Do you know, wait.
Tempo didn't even know CC was next week.
He thought it was the week after.
But I...
Oh, I thought so too.
Oh wait, what the fuck you do?
I thought it too, holy shit.
I did not know we were playing next week.
I do not have enough time to prep for that.
We are playing next week, guys!
Oh, we're so fucked.
This is good, this is good.
People are dying.
There's no one middle.
Do I go middle?
Inside?
Do it, do it, do it, do it, do it, do it, do it.
Do it and then like there might be heals.
There's heals, there's my box on my left.
On the left, that's me, that's me.
Right, right, right, right, here, right, here, right.
Here, behind you, that's my box.
I know, I'm nervous about them punching me in the face.
Just heal.
There's heals here.
No, you can't heal inside.
No, you can.
Yeah, yeah, what the fuck do you mean?
I put...
Hey, chill.
Nadi, chill, Nadi, chill.
Just leave, just leave, just leave.
Just heal, just heal.
It's... you have time.
I know, but they're gonna push.
They're gonna come in here and...
They're not gonna push.
And the other team's gonna come in there.
Yeah, and then you watch these two come inside.
Hey, they scare each other out.
You're safe.
Yeah, yeah, there's...
No one can come in because the moment they come in, someone else will come in.
Yeah.
It's a scare tactic.
Oh, they're just trying to scare you.
I'm fucking dead, I'm fucking dead.
They're trying to scare you.
Oh my god.
What the fuck just happened to me?
Top 10!
Let's go!
You got lost.
Both points.
You got lost so hard.
What the fuck was that?
What just happened to me?
What was that?
I'm being crazy though.
Top 10 show gets me.
Look at that.
No, it's okay.
We're above Greek.
Oh my god.
We actually got arced in the car.
We're above Greek.
That's all that matters.
Man.
You know what crazy there?
If that team's just not there to stick with an R star, we actually probably could get like top five again.
Yeah, we could.
It's actually insane how bad our luck is.
It's unreal.
Yeah.
I'm just saying, wait, the next time you headline...
No, I call POIs.
I'm getting the POI out of here.
Next time you have an idea.
Next time you have an idea, go against that idea as well.
Yo, what the...
Every idea I have, just make it the opposite.
That is insane.
I can't believe the headliner got bullied out of their POI.
I am.
To be fair, it's good that we got, you know, it's good that we finally got team practice, you know?
100%.
Because if we didn't before Challenger Circuit, I think it would have been even worse.
Wait, what are we playing for Challenger Circuit?
I mean, listen, my brain is fried after these six games.
I just told us to get in three-man Trident and boost into Fight Nightlight.
I mean, am I really capable of IGLing anyone at this point?
Okay, but also remember where you took us before we were in the Trident.
That was even...
We were...
I think we were safe down there.
I think too.
If the zone pulled off, we were good.
I didn't know that.
I did not feel safe.
I mean, if we just had a fucking beacon.
I did not feel safe at all.
One time today.
One time we had a...
Do you understand that in order to get a beacon today, we just had to send Tempo over to Harvester?
That was the only time we had a beacon.
We just dropped a literal manager of an esports team solo out of the OI to get a beacon.
We didn't get a single beacon.
That's actually crazy.
That is crazy.
All six games we had zero beacons.
We just played this game on all six.
It was a hard difficulty, literally veteran mode.
And it fucking back again.
God damn it.
Fuck me.
That's actually insane.
That's insane.
We had one game of beacon, right?
What was it?
No, we didn't.
We had to walk over to the beacon.
We...
Oh, no, no.
We had one at Jurassic.
Oh, we had Jurassic.
Yeah.
One out of five, baby.
One out of five.
Didn't we get fucked over in Jurassic still?
No.
No, we didn't.
We didn't.
We did pretty well.
No, we just needed a catwalk.
We would have made like top 5.
That's my bad.
We had a...
You know what?
In the end, we had a good vibe.
Honestly, I actually had so much fun today.
I'm just glad we weren't last.
Wait, wait, guys.
We're better than Reptar.
In the end, Reptar was rank 1 last season.
And we were...
Our team did better than him.
You're so fucking right.
We technically beat the rank 1 Pred.
So are we rank 1?
We beat rank 1 Pred as a Plat team.
Just remember that.
That's what I'm saying.
Hey, Full...
What's up?
You're in Platinum right now?
What?
Yeah.
Hey, see?
A full Platinum squad did better than Reptar.
Yeah, a full Platinum squad did better than Reptar.
Ranked 0.5.
We'll take that too.
That is our win.
That is our win today.
Oh, I know.
That is the only thing I'm taking home with pride today.
Better than Reptar.
I know Greek needs a shot of alcohol.
It's so bad right now.
The fact that Greek lost to us.
And just also, if he's getting 20th, then he didn't have a vibe squad like us.
Oh boy.
Oh boy, yeah, yeah.
He didn't get to have the fun part.
He didn't take a trident into a full team.
Wait, dude.
Come on, man.
You had no idea there was a team there.
It happened so fast.
I didn't even know what happened.
I knew things were going to be bad.
The thing you said was I'm going to do something that might not be a good idea, but it would be really funny.
That's what you said.
I mean, I sent you alone to 1v3 fist fight inside of Fight Night.
That's pretty funny.
You were getting your ass beat inside of Fight Night 1v3.
At least we got the content out of the way.
We got real content.
We had real content.
No other team had as much fun as us.
Who is this winning right now?
I don't know.
This team winning might have a good time.
They just wasted all their grenades.
They're not even pushing over yet.
Why did they just waste all their grenades?
Oh yeah, this is the watch party.
This is your watch party time.
Exactly.
Wig wanted to die early so he could watch party.
In game watch party.
Here you go, Chad.
Look at that.
And the win is going to go.
Nice.
Wow.
Look at that endgame.
Oh my god.
He won.
That might be Gen.
Gen Burn.
I think.
Oh, Gen.
Yeah, Gen 1.
Wait, do you actually memorize the skins?
Wasn't he like first place by like 30 points going into the game?
Yeah.
So did he just win by like 50 points?
Yeah, he lost by like 100 points.
Holy shit.
With girl too?
Girl's going crazy.
That was not us, guys.
I wonder what that's like.
I don't think we'll ever feel that.
No, we will.
It's challenger circuit.
I don't think we'll ever know what that feels like.
We got fucking wrenched.
Guys, don't worry.
Look at where team 14 is.
Good.
We're safe.
It would have been worrying if they got some kills.
Yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
We had zero kills.
Wait, how does team 20 have three kills?
And they died in 20th.
I don't know.
Wait, what?
Yeah.
Maybe they rez.
They could have got picks and then the people rez.
Maybe.
We did it, guys.
Guys.
Dude, what did we fucking get, man?
We had to get last.
No, we're second last because Green's team never got a single point.
Is that going to burn?
Oh, everyone gets the same amount.
Yeah, everyone gets 400.
11th to 20th all get the same amount.
Okay.
Yeah, so we're fine.
It doesn't matter what place we're at.
Technically, we're 11.
Okay, makes sense.
Yeah, everybody's 11th place.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Everybody is 11th place.
So, technically, we're all 11th place.
Except for Green, who's 12th.
What?
Apparently, the team above us in docks was Greek.
Wait, really?
I'm asking.
They were probably so confused why we took the Trident and left.
They were probably so dumbfounded.
That is unbelievable.
There's no fucking way.
They're taking the fucking Trident?
That is so fucking funny.
Look at us.
Look at us go.
I told you guys.
I bet you no one had as much fun as us.
Chad.
This was very good practice for Challenger Circuit.
Agreed.
Okay, so what did we learn today that we're going to take it to Challenger Circuit?
I think...
Never get beacons, so don't bother with the controller character.
That's not what we learned.
Thank God you understand what we learned today.
Thank God we are talking about this now.
What do you mean?
That's exactly what we learned.
What we learned is that we need a POI with a scan.
We need to figure out a POI.
And even if we're going to get contested, we still need to figure out a POI and not get bullied out of our POI.
Unlike today.
I agree.
And we need to figure out what to play.
Because apparently we might be playing this game for seven hours on Saturday.
Yep.
Seven hours of that.
We need to do better than that.
Yeah.
And it's going to be next week for sure.
Right?
Is it actually next week or did I just guess like you two think it's next week?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, it's next week.
Okay, okay.
It's actually next week.
Okay.
Oh my God, bro.
Your fucking chat, Wig.
I can see why Tempo is the manager.
Who said that?
Holy shit.
Wait a minute.
I have mod...
Oh, no, wait.
No, I know.
Alright.
Oh, yeah.
100%.
Oh, my chat.
My chat's crazy right now.
Yeah.
Yeah, I got shit on more today than I ever have in my life to be honest.
Wait, are you going to be interviewed because you're headlining this?
Hell no.
I was already interviewed.
Girls are going to get interviewed now.
What the fuck?
Are you going to be interviewed?
We should be having an interview for like the vibes.
I can't believe... I can't believe we didn't get...
I can't believe you didn't bring us to the interview.
I can't believe...
Yeah, they should get you on there.
No, they should have got all of us.
All of us.
Well, Nicewith told me three times to take a trident when I shouldn't have.
And, you know, he denied me all correctly one time.
But, you know, we had a good time today.
Yeah, we...
Yeah.
He said like this was...
The last thing I heard was this might be a really bad idea, but it's going to be funny.
This might be a really bad idea, but it's going to be funny.
Yeah.
He said this is going to be funny and then none of us laughed afterwards.
Yeah, and then we got Ark started.
I got confused.
I got so confused, I didn't know what was going on.
All I know is I got stunned.
And then there was people.
Tempo had a bladder issue too, so like honestly we should negate everything that happened.
Yeah.
We should just reset the scores.
Oh my god.
Reset and then multiply game one by six.
I don't think game one was the game that we did the best in.
It was like game four.
Yeah, we know.
We got like...
They won three games out of six.
Jen's team?
Yeah, that's fucking crazy.
Bro.
That could have been me.
If I was...
If Jen picked me.
You guys really got lost every game.
If Jen got you, he loses six out of six.
There's no way.
We should have like a control group here.
Every tournament, Jen will pick one of us and then see who plays us higher.
It's not going to be me.
Oh my god.
You're playing higher than me sadly.
We got to experiment here and see who's right.
That was so fucking fun, man.
Thank you guys so much.
I appreciate y'all for playing too.
Seriously guys.
That was really fun.
Maybe just fucking play some games soon or something like that if you guys want to.
Actually like ranked or anything.
We should really practice.
We should probably play a bit.
You guys want to practice this week?
I'm down?
Yeah.
Okay.
Should it be next week since CC is next week?
Oh yeah.
That's what I meant.
Like Monday.
My bad.
Wait.
Is it today Monday?
Today is Friday.
Is what?
What?
Nothing.
Temple.
Yeah.
It's Friday.
Wait.
What's...
Oh.
Wait.
Did you not think it was Friday?
I forgot what day it was.
What?
Temple.
How do you run shit so efficiently but just don't even know the day of the week?
You're impressive, man.
I actually love you so much.
You're like the most functional, unfunctional person I've ever met in my life.
Oh yeah.
Have you seen like...
Have you seen like all the...
Like all of his PC setup?
He has like five monitors or some shit.
Yeah.
It's like he's like...
And then Doki plastered all of her merch all over my screens.
Okay.
Not me.
It was like one of my...
One of my patents.
She's like, there you go.
You should buy all of this Doki merch.
Buy Doki merch.
His walls are so barren.
Have you seen his walls?
Also, wait.
You promised me you would buy like a Doki print and put it on your backdrop.
I promised you I'd buy it and then burn it.
I promised I'd buy it.
You said you would put it behind you.
I'll get it behind you and I'll put it behind me and I'll burn it.
Alright.
Do it.
Deal.
It's just your money.
Yeah.
It's just my money.
It's just a picture of you.
It's literally your money.
Oh yeah.
Speaking of...
Subs.
Oh my god.
How many do you deserve, Tempo?
What does the sub count actually?
Tempo got like...
Tempo got four kills.
Oh my god.
Did you?
That's 40 subs.
I thought you got five subs per kill.
No?
Oh yeah.
So 20 subs.
20 subs.
You said 20 subs for me and Tempo.
And then 20... No you said 20 subs for me and Tempo.
You just keep bumping up the number.
Yeah.
I'll do it.
Wait.
I can't gift Tempo subs.
What?
Are you not even an affiliate, Tempo?
Oh no.
I can't.
Oh it's gonna be like...
Alright.
20 gifted to Tempo.
Wait.
Gift one sub and I'm gonna give 20.
20 subs is $100?
Yay!
You got five kills?
Yeah.
You got five.
We have five kills.
Oh.
Tempo says 25.
I don't know who's kills these are.
I have an interview with the winners.
I have no idea what's going on.
Wait.
Can we join?
I'll ask them.
Okay.
Watch out.
I'll ask them too.
I'll try to get you guys in there.
We'll just be like, hey we're gonna be here to help.
I'll see.
One sec.
I'll try.
We just fucking crashed the interview.
Yeah.
By the way, Tempo, I made up that number.
I don't even know how many kills you got.
Yeah.
I don't know how many kills we got.
I see total kills as five.
So four.
We'll stay with five.
It says total kills.
He doesn't know.
He's not gonna fact check.
Yeah.
So five kills, right?
That's 25 subs for you.
It's payday.
Okay.
We're back.
What is Wig gonna do?
Review the VOD?
Exactly.
She's not gonna review the VOD.
Guys, I don't think Wig's gonna...
I don't think he's coming back.
I think he's gonna come back, but the interview's gonna be over.
He didn't bring us back to the room.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe he didn't bring us into the interview room.
He left us.
That's so fucked up.
He's about to...
He's about to interview now.
That's fucked up.
He didn't even tell us.
He didn't drag us in.
Oh my god.
He actually just went peace and left us.
I'm gonna message him.
Shake my head.
Actually left us.
Can't believe it.
He left for milk.
He actually left us.
We're like the only one... oh wait no, actually I was gonna say I thought we were like the only one in VC, but we can only see our own VCs.
Yeah.
And then the one above us.
We can click into the... oh no wait nevermind.
We can't click.
We just like... Guys we doubled...
We doubled Greek's score.
Did we double Greek's score?
Guys we doubled Greek's score.
We doubled his score.
Guys we did it!
We're better than the Rank 1 Pred last season.
Just remember that.
Any team... we're better than the team that was...
That had a Rank 1 Pred.
That's all it takes.
Oh my god.
Look last look!
It's cuz the current season doesn't have Rank 1 yet!
We don't know who's the current Rank 1 Pred yet this season.
We don't know.
We don't know!
So it doesn't matter, chat.
Yeah cuz it hasn't ended It didn't do it yet.
We're the strongest plat.
No, it didn't.
What do you mean?
The season is still ongoing.
Is ranked season still ongoing?
Oh right, it ends next week.
Yeah, it's still ongoing.
So we're good.
We're good.
We're good to go.
I think we did pretty well.
I think we did pretty well as a team.
I had zero expectations.
I still have zero expectations, but...
I thought we were going to get in the middle.
I know it wasn't going to happen.
I know.
With our POIs, there was no way.
Literally, we had zero good POIs.
Wig literally got kicked out of all the good POIs.
The last Twitch Rivals we did, Wig actually had decent places to land.
We actually had loot.
Let's see if they... that's true.
Yeah, we were what?
Grow towers?
We had loot.
Yeah, we had actual loot and we weren't getting contested.
This time, we got contested every time.
Or not every time.
We got kicked out of our areas.
Where's POI?
It's like... I forgot what was the abbreviation for POI?
It's like the landmarks.
So where you're landing.
I don't know what the abbreviation is.
I forgot.
POI?
Oh, POI.
Point of interest.
So it's basically where teams get to pick where you want to land the landmarks.
And then, um, Wig tried to pick good spots, but then every other team kicked us out.
Every team kicked us out of the spots.
So we got the spots that were considered absolutely trash loot with zero hope.
He's weak.
He's a little bitch.
Oh my god.
I don't even know how long this interview is going to be.
How long is this interview?
It just started.
Wait, they just started the interview?
Yeah.
Oh no.
They a- oh my god.
They just started the interview.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
How long are we going to be waiting here?
Yeah, the interview just started now.
Okay, if this interview is going to take really, really, really long, I might peace out soon.
I think it takes like three minutes.
15 minutes?!
Alright, GG's Tempo.
Tell Wig that I couldn't wait 15 minutes.
I couldn't wait...
GG's...
I have zero patience.
Alright, GG's Tempo.
You have to do your schedule, right?
Yeah, I have to do my schedule.
When did you want to play?
What do you mean?
When did you want to play, Wig?
I mean, most likely I won't be streaming it because I also have another Apex tournament too, other than CC.
So I don't want to put too many Apex on.
I'll most likely just play off... like, you guys can stream, but I'll play off stream.
Okay.
Alright, GG's Tempo.
Wait, you mean the one tomorrow, right?
What?
No, not that.
Next week.
I mean, next week I have a lot of... I have another... I have two...
Another Apex tournament other than the CC one.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
It's not been announced yet, so I can't really say much about it.
Oh, okay.
Gotcha.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright, GG's.
Bye.
I'll see you.
I'll see you tomorrow.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll see you tomorrow at finals.
Bye-bye.
Bye.
Alright, alright, guys.
I'm gonna call it here because, like, I actually... I cannot wait 15 minutes.
I don't want to watch... I don't want to watch an interview for 15 minutes, guys.
I don't want to watch it.
But I had a great time.
I had a great time.
I always love playing with Wig and Tempo.
We're just, like, fucking around.
I had very low expectations and it's not last.
I'm fine with that.
I'm fine.
We beat the Rank 1 Pred team.
That's fine with me.
I'm happy with that.
The fact that we weren't last is good enough for me.
It's good enough for me.
But it was honestly... it was really fun.
Yeah, it exceeded my very, very low expectations.
And I hope you guys had a fun time watching.
If you're new here, I usually stream on the YouTubes.
So please check me out over there.
Exclamation point socials to see all the social media stuff I have.
For Twitch streams, I usually tweet it out whenever I'm streaming on Twitch.
And so please follow me on Twitter to know for my Twitch updates.
What else?
Oh, yes.
If you want to support me via other means, please check out my merch.
Also, we're Twitch Pride Day!
This is my first Twitch Partner stream!
Thank you, everybody, for coming!
I hope you guys enjoyed the first Twitch...
I've never been Twitch Partner before.
This is the first time I've ever been Twitch Partner!
Thank you, everyone!
I hope you guys had a...
I hope you guys had a fun time coming up to my very first Twitch Partner stream.
Thank you for all the gifted subs, all the biddies, all the donations, all the follows.
I really, really, really do appreciate it, guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get a move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stood up for me, head to bed, because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!